So, auf geht's. Let's go.
Hast du eigentlich deinen Homesturfer noch? Ja, klar.
Soll ich sonst mal den ganzen Kram drauflaufen haben?
Oh, was ist das da oben rechts?
Keck, wait.
Was ist das da oben rechts?
Ah, das ist noch von gestern.
Die Kamera, die ich eingeblendet habe vom Bastel.
Von der Bastel-Ecke.
Ah, die kommt mal weg.
Ja, habe ich noch. Wieso?
Welchen meinst du davon?
Also aktuell habe ich den...
Ja, ich bin nicht so wirklich glücklich mit Unraid.
Aber mit dem ganzen anderen Scheiß auch nicht.
Also es ist wirklich doof, dass es nichts Simples irgendwie gibt für den Heimbereich.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich bin fast schon davor, mir auch ein Kubernetes-Cluster daheim zu bauen.
Und einfach YAML zu erstellen.
Aber dann hast du wieder Probleme.
Wo machst du deine VMs?
Du kannst zwar prinzipiell das auch in Kubernetes laufen,
das ist aber auch schon wieder irgendwie sinnlos.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaube, ich lasse es einfach so wie das.
Ne, also ich habe immer noch die HP-Kiste, ist es glaube ich.
Oder Dell?
Ne, HP.
HP, Micro, Server, Gen, irgendwas.
Keine Ahnung, der aktuelle halt.
Ja.
So ein Teil habe ich immer noch.
Gen 10 plus V2.
Ich glaube, V2 habe ich noch nicht.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen V1 und V2?
Äh, haben die irgendwo...
Jetzt nervt nicht rum, Alter.
Haben die irgendwo vielleicht...
Beschreibung, was da für eine CPU drin ist?
Ja, das stimmt schon, aber du musst dich da trotzdem um so viel Zeug selbst kümmern.
Man könnte auch ESX nehmen, man könnte auch irgendwie irgendein Kubernetes...
Also irgendein OS nehmen, was das schön packt.
Aber das ist alles so viel Aufwand.
Also Unraid ist gar nicht so übel, was das angeht.
Du hast eine simple Oberfläche für VMs und Container.
Aber so wirklich der weiße letzter Schluss ist es auch nicht.
Ey, heißt nicht, ist komisch das für den Heimbereich.
Also am einfachsten...
Fährt man im Heimbereich, glaube ich, echt, wenn man sich ein Synology NAS kauft.
Was ist denn jetzt der Unterschied zwischen V2?
Okay, Microserver Gen V2 versus V1.
Ja, just spotted.
Ich auch.
Okay.
Warum ist Reddit eigentlich kaputt?
Seit gestern.
So lahm.
Okay, der internal USB-Port ist 3.1.
Ja, das interessiert mich nicht so viel.
TPM.
Okay, integrate.
New options are new.
Okay, es gibt neue Pentium.
New...
Also...
Okay, es hält sich echt in Grenzen.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Ich behalte das Ding jetzt, bis es auseinanderfällt oder ich irgendwas Besseres finde.
Ich weiß auch nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, ich bin echt über den Heimbereich, was so Self-Hosting-Sachen angeht, nicht ganz glücklich.
Es gibt zwar immer mehr, aber ich habe noch nichts gefunden, was ich so richtig gut finde.
Es ist genauso mit Monitoring für daheim.
Ich habe seit einer ganzen Weile ein Zabbix, weil es immer noch die beste Kombination...
...ist aus.
Du kannst alles mögliche überwachen und musst nicht allzu viel selbst machen.
Aber selbst das ist scheiße.
Irgendwie manchmal, muss ich ehrlich sagen, da kommt der Boomer durch.
Manchmal, wo ich denke, die Zeiten, wo es nicht 30 Milliarden Tools gab und keins hat dich so richtig überzeugt,
war fast besser zu Zeiten, wo es nur 1, 2 Tools gab.
Die haben dich zwar auch nicht so richtig überzeugt, aber du wusstest, du musst die nehmen oder du hast gelitten.
Ja, das habe ich, das reicht mir aber nicht.
Das kann ja wirklich nur reporten, ist up oder down.
Das kann weder Checks über SSH, noch hast du eine History beispielsweise, was Plattenplatz angeht und ordentliche Benachrichtigungen sind auch ein bisschen eklig.
Also wobei, das noch am ehesten geht.
Es ist auch nicht für mich sinnig gewesen.
Ich habe immer noch ein Zabbix am Start.
Die Stromkosten gehen bei mir tatsächlich.
Mein Rack braucht eitel irgendwie 80 Watt oder so.
Und da ist alles drin, ja.
Die Fritzbox, die Unity Media Router, mein Switch, mein Server, ein Raspberry Pi, ein Router, also 80 Watt eitel ist schon vollkommen in Ordnung für das ganze Ding.
Allein schon der Switch braucht 15, der Home Server wird eitel auch 20 brauchen.
Dann auch die ganzen anderen, das ist vollkommen okay.
Wahrscheinlich sogar mittlerweile weniger.
Ich habe nämlich gar nicht mehr gemessen seit dem Neuen.
Was?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich würde mal sagen, das was man so standardmäßig im Durchschnitt bezahlt, werde ich auch bezahlen.
Ich weiß nicht, was sind so die Durchschnittspreise aktuell.
Weiß nicht.
Wie findest du den Mini PC?
Ich weiß nicht, ich schicke mal einen Link zu.
Also ich habe einen Mini PC hier von Minisforum.
UM690.
Minisforum.
So einen Teil habe ich bei mir.
Warum auch immer die zu sehen.
Ich weiß nicht, warum die zusammen bestehen, aber so sieht das, so sieht das aus.
Ich vermute, ah hier, hier, nein, den da, den habe ich aber als Emulations-Konsolen-Ding.
Ich glaube in Kombination mit 32 GB RAM und einer 512 GB SSD, aber ich habe noch einen 2. SSD eingebaut.
Hongkong.
Ja, so ein Teil habe ich.
Mini PC-Skiko, ich kann mir das mal angucken.
Weiß nicht, sagt mir jetzt so erstmal nichts.
Beste Mini-PCs.
Na, wenn die das, wenn der Hersteller das sagt, dann muss das schon stimmen.
Sind wir uns ja einig drüber.
Hersteller sagen prinzipiell ja immer die Wahrheit über ihre Produkte.
Die sehen auf dem Bild gar nicht so mini aus, die Dinger.
Haben ganz gute Anschlüsse hier, ordentlich, ordentlich viel USB.
HDMI, sogar ein Display-Port-Output.
Vorne noch ein paar USBs, USB-C.
Anschluss für Mikrofon, ja.
Und an Hardware drinnen.
Ja, kostet.
Kostet ungefähr das gleiche wie den Mini-PC, den ich habe, in ungefähr der gleichen Konfiguration.
Ja.
Macht doch ganz brauchbaren Eindruck.
Ist halt die Frage, was die Geräusche, wie die Geräuschentwicklung ist.
Das, das bei so Mini-PCs, wobei der ganz schön, ganz schön, ganz schön pepo-fett aussieht.
Für Mini-PC.
Ist halt die Frage, wie die Geräuschentwicklung ist.
Das müsste man tatsächlich mal in einem Test nachlesen, aber ansonsten macht es auch einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Hast du Tipps für Einsteiger im Linux-Bereich?
Home-Projekte oder ähnliches?
Das ist ein bisschen die Frage, auch wie, ob ich, ob ich Einsteiger-Empfehlungen habe, so, oder was man als Programmierprojekte machen kann.
Und da sage ich jetzt einfach mal die Standardantwort, die ich da immer dafür habe.
Wurde der Stream gestern nicht gespeichert?
Ne, ich habe den Stream gelöscht, weil ich habe die letzten eineinhalb, also die letzte Stunde, ich fand das übelst langweilig.
Ich habe die letzte Stunde, ohne dass man richtig was gesehen hat, an dem Thermostat rumgebaut.
Das ist langweilig.
Das schmeiße ich weg.
Hast du Tipps für den Einsteiger?
Also, ey, was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen?
Genau, also das gleiche wie bei Software, bei Softwareprojekten.
Wichtig, wichtig ist, dass du dir erstmal überlegst, welcher Bereich interessiert dich.
Weil das hat ja keinen Sinn.
Sagen wir mal, du interessierst dich jetzt vielleicht für irgendwelche Cloud-Geschichten.
Und ich sag dir, schließ ein paar Sensoren an Raspberry Pi an.
So, weißt du?
Also, das sind ja zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Da langweilst du dich oder denkst du, so ein Scheiß, was soll ich damit?
Weil du lieber Cloud-Sachen bauen willst, anstatt irgendwelche Sensoren an deinen Raspberry Pi anschließen.
Also, du musst dir erstmal überlegen, was du eigentlich machen willst, in welchem Bereich, was dich interessiert.
Also, was interessiert dich denn?
Ansonsten, wenn du gar keine Ahnung hast und einfach ein bisschen dich mit Linux auseinandersetzen willst,
dann würde ich sagen, scheiß erstmal auf Raspberry Pi, Server und sonst was.
Installiere deine VM.
Mit Linux drauf.
Deiner Wahl.
Mint.
Ubuntu.
Und versuch das mal für tägliche Aufgaben ein bisschen zu verwenden.
Das ist in der VM vollkommen okay, solange du nicht gerade Videos encoden willst oder irgendwie viel 4K-Videos gucken willst oder so in der VM.
Wenn du ein bisschen nicht mit Linux auseinandersetzen willst, installiere dir das in der VM.
Und versuch da mal tägliche Aufgaben mit zu erledigen.
Das nächste ist, installiere dir einen Arch Linux.
Du kannst den Arch Installer verwenden.
Und richte dir das mal so ein, dass dir das gefällt.
Also sprich, installiere deine grafische Oberfläche.
Am besten natürlich I3, by the way.
Weil ich...
I3 ist der einzige, die einzige...
Ja, der einzige Desktop kann man ja nicht korrekterweise, kann man das ja so nicht nennen.
I3 ist die einzige grafische Oberfläche, die mich nicht abfuckt unter Linux.
Also deswegen benutze ich halt I3.
Wenn du das alles eingerichtet hast, so dass es dir gefällt.
Und du das für tägliche Aufgaben benutzt.
Also von, kopieren wir mal ein paar Dateien auf einen USB-Stick.
Oder ich gucke mal im Internet schnell was nach.
Vielleicht installierst du dich auch für irgendwelche bisschen Sachen, Skripten.
Wenn du das alles über deine VM machst und Windows erstmal nur benutzt für das, wo es halt auch wirklich sinnvoll ist, was nicht gescheit unter Linux geht.
Zum Beispiel irgendwelche...
Ladder Games.
League of Legends.
Irgendwas, was die Leute gerne machen.
Valorant.
Was auch immer.
Zu spielen.
Zu streamen.
Videoschnitt und sonst was.
Wo du nicht unter Linux klarkommst.
Das machst du mit Windows.
Den Rest machst du unter Linux.
Und dann hast du ungefähr so ein Setup irgendwann wie ich am Start.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert mittlerweile gar nicht mehr.
sudo rm-rf/.
Ich glaube, die haben da mittlerweile eine Sicherheitsvorkehrung eingebaut, dass das nicht mehr funktioniert.
Ich glaube, das sagt dir.
Wenn du rm-rf/. machst, so wollen sie das wirklich machen.
Ich glaube, du musst no-preserve-root oder sowas eingeben sogar, dass das funktioniert.
Ja, und dann wirst du dann irgendwann zu so einem Setup wie ich hier übergehen.
Dass du hier deine VM hast und hier dein Windows.
Und wenn du das alles ordentlich eingerichtet hast und das täglich benutzt, dann lernst du viel über Linux.
Gerade so im normalen Handling und Kommandozeilenhandling und so die Standardbefehle, die man braucht.
Und du machst bestimmt auch schon das ein oder andere Bash-Skript und lernst halt die Sachen.
Ja, besser als sich gleich irgendwie einen Server hinzustellen mit Diensten drauf, auf die man sich verlässt.
Besser ist, du installierst den Linux vm und versuchst da einfach täglich ein bisschen mitzuarbeiten und die Sachen so zu lösen, die du halt so an Problemen hast.
Das Ganze erst mal unter vor allem Workstation auf deinem Windows-Rechner gemacht.
Ja, klar, siehst du auch hier.
Guck mal.
Ist vor allem Workstation.
Da.
Würde ich.
Was heißt erst mal Workstation?
Ja.
Immer.
Ich finde, das ist das beste Setup.
Gibt's, gibt's zwar Leute, die widersprechen mir da.
Ich erinnere mich noch an das eine YouTube-Video, was auf, wer auf mein Video reactet hat.
Wo dann sogar einer bei mir in den Kommentaren geschrieben hat.
Max, den musst du verklagen.
Ich hab mir auch gedacht, was ist mit euch los?
Das Video war doch vollkommen normal.
Aber Hauptsache erst mal random Leute verklagen auf YouTube.
Gut.
Scheint ja mittlerweile gang und gäbe zu sein, was ich so wieder mitgekriegt hab die letzten Wochen auf YouTube.
Ich hab mir gedacht, dass sich irgendwelche YouTuber untereinander abmahnen und dann reagieren 50.000 andere YouTuber drauf, wo dann wieder drauf reagiert wird.
Und die ursprünglich Reaction-Leute reacten auf die Reactions.
Ah, das ist echt nicht mehr.
Also YouTube-Deutschland ist so für ein Arsch aktuell.
Oder was heißt aktuell?
Eigentlich die letzten Jahre über schon.
Wobei ich sagen muss, also ich hab den Eindruck, dass YouTube-Deutschland besonders beschissen ist.
Wobei man sagen muss, so im YouTube-International ist wahrscheinlich genauso beschissen.
Kriege ich aber nicht so oft empfohlen.
Weil ich einfach nicht diese ganzen Channels gucke.
Was hast du für ein Terminal-Theme?
Ein selbstgebautes.
Also basieren tut das Ganze auf Tomorrow Night.
Also kannst du dir das hier angucken. Guck mal.
Auf Wobblors Github.
Ah, mein Auge juckt.
So, Wobblors Github.
Gehst du hier in meine ZSHRC.
Ne, Quatsch. Nicht ZSHRC.
Was erzähl ich denn für ein Mist?
Du gehst in mein Terminal-Config.
Da, siehst du es.
Und da ist mein Colorscheme.
Das hält sich tatsächlich in Grenzen.
Das ist mein Farbschema.
Hier. Alles, alles.
Also es basiert auf Tomorrow Night.
Aber ich hab ein paar Sachen angepasst von dem standardmäßig included in Tomorrow Night.
Ein paar Sachen hab ich angepasst.
Ich glaube eine Sache, die ich angepasst hab, ist die Cursor-Karte.
Die Selection-Color.
Dass die nicht so kacke aussieht.
Und...
Genau. Cursor-Color, Selection-Color.
Und ansonsten glaube ich war es das, was ich angepasst hab.
Also das ist das Terminal-Theme.
Und das hier ist Starship.
Und da gibt es auch...
Hier. Starship-Tommel.
Ja. Da hast du den ganzen Kram.
Das ist...
Aber nicht...
Ich hab mir das nicht komplett selbst ausgedacht.
Ich hab als Basis das hier genommen.
Das Preset, was dabei ist.
Hier.
Pastel-Powerline.
Was wiederum selbst auf M365-Princess basiert.
Was auch immer.
Wer die Dinger so benennt.
Aber ich hab das umgebaut von einem einstelligen Prompt zu einem zwei- oder zweizeiligen Prompt.
Weil ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch aussieht.
Ich hab glaub ich schon ein paar mal gefragt, ob ihr lieber einzeilige Prompts oder zweizeilige Prompts mögt.
Ich glaube das ist so 50-50.
Ich persönlich mag zweizeilige Prompts.
Und das liegt ganz einfach daran.
Zum Beispiel, wenn wir jetzt mal hier in irgendeinen Sub-Ordner gehen.
Gehen wir mal hier in irgendeinen Sub-Ordner, wo wir relativ viel Ordner haben.
Dann kann man hier den Ordner sich anzeigen lassen.
Wo man gerade drin ist.
Sogar hierfür, das ist zu lang.
Und man hat immer noch Platz hier unten.
Man kann hier Infos anzeigen lassen, wie die Node-Version, auf die das aufbaut und sonst was.
Oder gehen wir mal hier in den...
Sagen wir im .NET Projekt.
Dann sieht man hier das Verzeichnis, Git-Branche, installiertes .NET, Target .NET Version und sowas in der Richtung.
Und stellt euch mal vor, das wäre alles nur einzeilig.
Dann könnte ich hier jetzt erst schreiben.
Und hier habe ich noch die Wurzel.
Also, das ist wirklich mega kacke.
Deswegen habe ich einfach das ganze zweizeilig gemacht.
Und man hat immer Platz an der gleichen Stelle und weiß, wo man hingucken muss.
Außerdem hat man eh genug Space im Terminal.
Also ich mag zweizeilige Prompts.
Dann habe ich noch ein bisschen die Schriftart geändert, ein paar Sachen angepasst.
Beim großen und ganzen...
Ja.
Es ist gar nicht so viel Unterschied dazu.
Und das ist die Kombination, was ich in der Shell und Terminal eingerichtet habe.
Kennst du Btop? Ja, haben wir sogar installiert.
Das einzige, was man einstellen sollte bei Btop ist, dass der den Hintergrund vom Terminal benutzt und nicht den eigenen Hintergrund.
Btop.
Brauche ich aber nicht so sehr, weil...
Guckt mal.
Wenn ich jetzt...
Ich habe hier oben ja, wenn ich ein bisschen Last im Terminal...
Guckt euch mal das hier oben an.
Wenn ich ein bisschen Last im Terminal verursache, das ist meine CPU-Kernauslastung.
Das reicht mir meistens, ganz ehrlich.
Zu 90%, wenn man Top auf seinem Desktop aufruft, ist es doch, weil man denkt, irgendwas läuft im Hintergrund und hängt.
Und dann macht man Top auf.
Und wenn ich hier oben sehe, dass ein CPU-Core komplett auf 100% Anschlag hängt, dann weiß ich gleich, okay, da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Welche VM vor allem bei Workstation?
Also hier oben habe ich direkt in der Leiste Überblick, was abgeht.
Meine Load, CPU-Auslastung pro Core und CPU insgesamt, Disk, RAM.
Das ist übrigens RAM, nicht CPU.
Ich erzähle Blödsinn.
RAM, Disk, Datum und eine Uhrzeit.
Datum und eine Uhr.
Ein Countdown.
Timer, falls man mal einen braucht.
Fertig.
Jo.
Und ansonsten, wenn du Server-mäßig was bauen willst, würde ich mich erstmal mit so den gängigen Sachen vertraut machen.
Ich würde mir mal einen Debian installieren, kannst du auch in der VM machen.
Dort SSH beispielsweise so einrichten mit einem Client, dass du dich per Keys authentifizieren kannst.
Und erstmal, bevor du irgendwelche großen Projekte machst, guck dir erstmal die Basics an.
Da kommst du dann besser mit klar.
Und wenn du dann irgendwann mal soweit bist, dann ist dir hoffentlich ein ordentliches Projekt eingefallen.
Irgendwas, was du auch brauchst.
Von ein bisschen Heimautomatisierung zu irgendwelchen Programmierprojekten, irgendwelche Webseiten hosten, Zertifikate ausstellen, was auch immer.
Gibt es halt alle möglichen Sachen.
Die Basics machen wir erstmal, korrekt.
So sieht es aus.
Hersteller sagen prinzipiell immer die Wahrheit.
Prime Subscriber übrigens auch.
To Do App.
Ja Moment, es geht ja nicht um Programmierprojekte, sondern um Linux-Einsteigerprojekte.
Eine To Do App.
Eine Debian To Do App, was auch immer.
Oh, ein Kubernetes Cluster auf.
Beste Idee zum Einstieg erstmal ein Kubernetes Cluster.
Vor allem, weil Kubernetes selbst zu hosten auch so eine gute Idee ist.
Ja, habe ich.
Kann ich dir auch empfehlen.
Vor allem bei Workstation.
Ist für mich die beste Virtualisierungslösung, die es gibt hier für Windows.
Und du kannst dir einen billigen Key besorgen.
Ich verrate dir jetzt nicht wie.
Also bei Keyshops kannst du dir welchen kaufen.
Aber insgesamt findest du billige Keys.
Wobei ich wenige Kram gekauft habe.
Ja, so mache ich das auch.
Gaming, Videokram, Streaming über Windows und Proggas, Netzwerk und Bastelzeug unter Linux.
Und das ohne Dualboot, weil ich persönlich keinen Dualboot mag.
Wie heißt, Alter, gucken wir jetzt doch gerade mal.
Wie hieß der?
Wie hieß der Channel, der auf mein, mein, mein Linux?
Ja.
Reacted hat.
Okay.
Lass doch mal gucken, ob der irgendwelche anderen Videos hat, wo wir mal drauf reacten können.
Wo ist denn das Video?
Hier.
Linux YouTuber reagiert.
Hat der irgendwas?
Meine fünf Tipps für Linux einsteigen.
Das hätte ich auch gern gehabt.
Okay, da könnten wir vielleicht drauf reacten.
Wochenrückblick Debian.
Zehn Gründe, warum du nicht Linux nutzen solltest.
Okay, das erinnert mich so ein bisschen.
Ja.
Lass mal kurz durchgucken.
Was sind die zehn Gründe?
Benutzerfreundliche Spezialtreiber, Software-Kompatibilität, Gaming unter Linux, Hardware-Kompatibilität, Gewöhnungskompetenz.
Gewöhnungsbedarf, Zerstrittenheit und Umgangsvielfalt von Linux in Oberflächen, Verbreitung.
Ja, gut.
Vieles davon habe ich ja auch gesagt.
Snap.
Morgen KS.
China, Chinesen, Linux.
Linux Mint versus Debian.
Ist ganz einfach.
Linux Mint auf dem Desktop, Debian auf dem Server.
Easy.
Fertig.
Aus.
Du benutzt gerade Linux, um einen Stream zu schauen.
Ja.
Was ist das?
Fuzzy Finder.
Benutze ich auch, aber recht wenig.
Also ich habe mir zum Beispiel was mit FZF, falls ihr das kennt, Fuzzy Finder gebaut.
Und zwar für die Arbeit.
Ich liste mir mit Gcloud CLI alle VMs in der Google Cloud auf und pipe das dann nach FZF.
Dann kann ich dann drinnen suchen und selecten und dann kann ich mich per SSH drauf verbinden.
Hat das gestern mit den Bosch Thermostaten geklappt?
Ja.
Aber nicht alles.
Und ich habe es auch noch nicht mit SIG B2M QTT probiert, womit es wohl besser funktionieren soll und auch Firmware Updates unterstützt.
Also das Einbinden hat sofort geklappt.
First try.
Das Einstellen nach einem Reboot vom Zertifikat, nachdem ich es an die Heizung montiert habe, hat auch das Einstellen von Temperatur und so ohne Probleme funktioniert.
Und der Motor innen drin hat auch gesteuert.
Was nicht ging und was für mich so komplett pepega ist, dass es nicht geht, ist, man konnte es nicht ausschalten.
Was enorm wichtig ist.
Weil wenn du das nicht ausschalten kannst, dann braucht das einfach viel zu viel Strom.
Wenn du das ausschalten kannst den ganzen Sommer über, dann brauchst du quasi fast ein halbes Jahr, sagen wir jetzt mal aufgerundet, in Deutschland vielleicht ein bisschen weniger, brauchst du fast ein halbes Jahr kaum Energie für die Thermostate.
Und deswegen halten die Dinger auch eineinhalb, zwei Jahre mit den Batterien drinne.
Wenn es jetzt die ganze Zeit an ist und selbst wenn du es nur runterdrehst auf fünf Grad oder so, es sackt halt.
Es ist halt doof, dass du es nicht ausschalten kannst.
Du kannst es ausschalten.
Also es gibt eine Heizpause, die man einschalten kann.
Aber man kriegt es irgendwie nicht richtig eingeschaltet am Thermostat selber, weil die Bedienung von dem Thermostat mit den Knöpfen hyperpepega ist.
Und man kann es halt nicht über die offizielle App machen, weil ich die offizielle App nicht benutzen kann.
Mal gucken, wie das mit SIG P2M QTT ist.
Muss ich mal ausprobieren die Tage.
Reicht heute Mittag.
Ist B-Top im Browser.
Du kannst, also wenn du einen Zugriff per Browser brauchst.
Du kannst irgendein Web-SSH machen.
Wenn es unbedingt sein muss.
Web-SSH und dann auf die Kiste drauf.
Aber warum muss es denn unbedingt im Browser sein?
Das würde mich jetzt interessieren.
RedHatBarry, warum muss es unbedingt vom Browser Web-Zugriff mit irgendeinem Kommandozeilentool sein?
Warum muss es unbedingt vom Browser Web-Zugriff mit irgendeinem Kommandozeilentool sein?
Ich meine wie gesagt, du kannst auch SSH über Web machen.
Mittlerweile.
Webshell-Geschichten.
Du kannst ja alles benutzen.
Wobei, das weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das im produktiven Server nicht unbedingt drauf haben wollen.
Was meinst du mit ProGas-Programmieren?
Das ist...
Ja, wir haben schon für alles ein bisschen bescheuerte Wörter.
ProGas ist für mich Programmieren.
Das ist das Gegenstück zu Pogas.
ProGas ist ein Twitch-Emote und ProGas ist ProGas-Programmieren quasi.
Leute, ich muss da mal wieder was sagen.
Wisst ihr was mich übelst aufregt?
habe ich das jetzt auch versucht, hier nicht so zu antworten.
Die typische, hätte auf diese Frage, die typische Forenantwort wäre gewesen,
oh, warum willst du denn sowas machen?
Mach das doch lieber anders.
Und solche Antworten regen mich immer auf.
Deswegen habe ich gesagt, vielleicht kannst du ja ein Web-Terminal installieren.
Aber mich würde trotzdem interessieren, warum das unbedingt per Web-Zugriff sein muss.
Red Hat Barry.
Vielleicht bist du ja noch da.
Kannst ja mal im Chat geschrieben.
Ja, also eine Sache, die mich immer übelst aufregt,
und das hatte ich letzte Woche auf der Arbeit, und zwar,
wir verwenden auf der Arbeit natürlich kein Let's Encrypt.
Let's Encrypt wäre viel zu einfach zum Zertifikate ausstellen.
Wir benutzen irgendeinen Zertifikatservice von irgendeinem Anbieter,
der aber glücklicherweise sich auch über ACME,
spricht man das überhaupt so aus, automatisieren lässt.
Also du kannst Zertmanager und sowas benutzen,
aber du brauchst irgendwie ein Custom-Plugin und so, dass das funktioniert.
Ganz weird, Champ.
Na gut.
Zumindest wollte ich das letzte Woche machen mal.
Hab ich Kubernetes-Cluster, Zertmanager installiert,
hab das versucht einzurichten,
und da ist mir aufgefallen, ja, Moment,
bevor ich das jetzt einrichte
und 50 Mal meinen Helm-Chart-Aninstaller installiere
und neue Zertifikate anfordere,
frag doch mal, was das für Limits hat.
Weil, Chat, habt ihr euch schon mal ausgesperrt bei Let's Encrypt?
Hat schon mal jemand die Ehre gehabt, sich auszusperren bei Let's Encrypt?
Weil er entweder nicht Staging benutzt hat
oder zu oft die gleichen Einträge abgefragt hat?
Eine Woche warten, ja.
Genau.
Es gibt übrigens einen Trick bei Let's Encrypt,
wie man das etwas mehrmals, ja,
hat wahrscheinlich jeder gerade am Anfang schon mal auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Also, es gibt einen Trick bei Let's Encrypt,
das versuche ich euch mal,
kurz zu erklären.
Also, Let's Encrypt hat ja,
hat ja mehrere Limits.
Insgesamt Limits,
Limits pro Request und sowas,
Zertifikate pro registrierte Domain,
bis zu 100 Namen per Zertifikat
und sowas in der Richtung, so.
Wenn ihr in das allgemeine Limit lauft,
dann habt ihr gelitten.
Aber, was geht ist,
ihr könnt, also mal angenommen,
ihr möchtet,
ein Zertifikat ausstellen für
www.kapperlull.com
oder sagen wir mal, ihr wollt ein Wildcard sogar ausstellen,
ihr wollt sowas ausstellen hier, ja.
Alles von unterhalb www.kapperlull.com
und ihr habt das zu oft gemacht und Let's Encrypt sagt euch,
nope, gibt's nicht mehr.
Dann macht einfach folgendes,
dann stellt ein Zertifikat,
dann macht einen neuen Zertifikat-Request
und fragt zusätzlich im gleichen Zertifikat-Request
noch das Zertifikat dafür an.
Das funktioniert.
Also, bei Let's Encrypt zählt nicht nur die Domain,
sondern es zählt der, wie heißt es, der SN?
Ne, wie heißt denn das im Zertifikat?
Also der Name, also es zählen alle Domains,
ich weiß nicht, Subjects?
Wie heißt denn dieser Blödsinn im Zertifikat nochmal?
Also es zählt die komplette Kombination aus den ganzen Namen im Zertifikat.
Also sprich, wenn ihr eigentlich nur das hier haben wollt
und Let's Encrypt hat euch gesagt,
und Let's Encrypt hat euch gesperrt,
dann fragt einfach noch im gleichen Request
etwas anderes an für die Domain,
dann zählt das als neuer Request,
weil es eben nicht exakt die gleiche Sache ist.
Das funktioniert.
Das globale Insgesamtlimit könnt ihr damit nicht umgehen,
aber für bestimmte Subdomains könnt ihr es damit umgehen,
falls ihr mal in der misslichen Lage seid
und euch ausgesperrt habt bei Let's Encrypt.
Das funktioniert umgedreht übrigens genauso.
Wenn ihr www angefragt habt,
dann könnt ihr zusätzlich noch einfach www2 oder so,
anfragen und dann geht das auch wieder.
Aber wie gesagt, nicht das globale Limit,
nur das für die einzelnen Einträge kann man,
wenn man die ändert, dann funktioniert das wieder.
So und jetzt kommen wir mal zu dem,
was mich genervt hat.
Ich habe auf der Arbeit gesagt,
hier sagt mal,
wie ist denn das mit unserem Zertifikatsanbieter?
Was haben wir denn da für Limits,
bevor ich jetzt 50 mal das aninstalle und installiere
und dann haben wir irgendein Limit?
Und wisst ihr, was die Antwort war?
Anstatt zu sagen,
oh ich weiß nicht,
ich muss mal gucken,
haben dann zwei Leute sinnlos darüber diskutiert,
warum man das nicht irgendwie anders machen kann
und das fuckt mich immer unglaublich ab.
Wisst ihr, ich frage ganz konkret,
wie ist denn das Limit für Zertifikatsanfragen?
Haben die irgendwie ein Limit?
Nur für den Fall der Fälle,
dass man sich mal irgendwie vertippt
oder zu viel aninstallt.
Ja, das erste was kam so nach dem Motto,
ja, kannst du nicht in deinem Helmchart
einfach TLS erstmal disablen und es ausprobieren
und erst dann, wenn es wieder akut wird,
TLS enablen.
Doch, doch, das kann ich schon machen,
aber ich will einfach nur die Limits wissen
für den Fall der Fälle.
Man weiß ja nie,
es kann natürlich auch sein,
dass sich einer mal vertippt
und gerade wenn es kaputt ist,
dass man auch daran denkt,
es könnte Zertifikatslimit sein.
Nee, da muss man schon gucken,
dass man das ordentlich macht.
Boah, hat mich das abgefuckt.
Das war das erste Mal,
dass mich das so richtig aufgeregt hat auf der Arbeit.
Die Leute wussten es nicht, ja.
Die wollten einfach nicht sagen,
sie wussten es nicht.
Glücklicherweise,
glücklicherweise,
habe ich danach jemanden angeschrieben
mit der gleichen Frage,
wie ist das so mit Limits?
Und er hat tatsächlich gesagt,
weiß er nicht,
aber er vermutet,
die Limits sind sehr hoch,
sie hatten noch nie Probleme
und ich soll mir erstmal keine Gedanken machen.
Sollte ich irgendwie an Limits stoßen,
ich soll auch gar nicht versuchen,
ich soll es auch gar nicht versuchen,
irgendwie zu umschiffen.
Ich soll ruhig mal richtig,
richtig Gas geben.
Und gucken,
ob ich da irgendwas raus finde.
Aber laut Google gibt es da also keine Limits.
Es gibt wohl irgendwie insgesamt
Request 10.000 Stück oder so,
was kein Problem ist.
Und das war wenigstens eine hilfreiche Antwort.
Ja, da hat er es dann noch alles eingetragen und so.
Aber die anderen erstmal sinnlos diskutiert.
Ja, muss man das denn überhaupt machen?
Ich wollte einfach nur die Limits wissen.
Ist das jetzt,
ist das jetzt irgendwie
ganz furchtbar ketzerische Frage gewesen,
dass man es nicht kaputt machen will oder wie?
Das ist immer ätzend.
Ja, gestern meinte der Chat ja,
ich soll es mal ausprobieren.
Das ist Müll.
Das ist richtig Müll.
Ich mag das überhaupt nicht.
Windows in der VM und dann Grafikkarte durchreichen.
Da hast du viel mehr Probleme im Endeffekt.
Da musst du gucken,
okay, wie kriegst du die grafische Ausgabe
auf dein Hauptmonitor,
wenn du die Grafikkarte durchreichst?
Wie kriegst du USB und Tastaturgeräte
in deine VM, um zu spielen?
Und das alles möglichst lagfrei.
Es ist,
es ist nicht schön.
Ganz ehrlich,
die beste Kombination,
also ich gebe dir recht,
dass Dual Boot stinkt,
aber Grafikkarte durchreichen ist auch Müll.
Das aus meiner Sicht Beste ist
Windows und Linux in der VM,
weil man in der VM alles machen kann,
was man will.
Und außer vielleicht so Sachen wie Video Decoding,
Video Encoding,
weil eben keine Grafikkarten,
Decoder und Encoder am Start sind.
Und ansonsten vollkommen egal.
Ja,
kannst du alles mitmachen.
Ja, das ist gut, wenn man es braucht,
aber es ist nicht jetzt sinnvoll
für die meisten Anwendungsfälle.
Wenn man, wenn man GPU passt,
oder generell PCI passt,
muss man ja sagen,
braucht es das sinnvoll?
Ja klar, habe ich auch schon gemacht
mit einer 10 GB Netzwerkkarte zum Beispiel
oder mit einem kompletten,
mit einem kompletten
SAS Controller.
Habe ich auch schon gemacht.
Passt.
Funktioniert.
Aber ich mag GPU passt du nicht
und das dann als Alternative für Windows.
Das mag in manchen Fällen
für manche Leute funktionieren,
aber so pauschal.
Du fängst dir damit wie gesagt
auch durchaus einige Probleme ein.
Zum Beispiel wie kriegst du die Ausgabe
von der Grafikkarte auf den Monitor
auf den gleichen Monitor wie dein Linux
kriegst du schon mal nett
und einfach das dann im Fenster anzeigen lassen
wie hier unter Linux ist dann auch nett,
weil die Grafikkarte ist durchgereicht.
Das heißt die Grafikkarte gibt auch die Sachen
nur aus an einem HDMI Ausgang oder so.
Dann brauchst du einen zweiten Monitor,
schaltest entweder den Monitor um,
hast zwei Inputs am Monitor.
Dann nimmst du was wie Looking Glass,
dann hast du immer einen Ein-Frame-Delay,
was nicht wild ist bei 240 FPS,
aber trotzdem.
Also es ist alles nicht so schön,
wie man das gerne hätte.
Ja problematisch nur,
wenn du dich aussperrst beim
Wildcard Zertifikate ausstellen.
Wie hast du eigentlich deine privaten Daten?
Rechnung, Schriftverkehr,
liegen die alle auf der Windows-Kiste
oder auf einem Server?
Nee, ganz einfach.
Das meiste Zeug kriege ich per Papier,
immer noch, auch vom Finanzamt und alles.
Und ich habe einfach im Schrank
obere, oberes Abteil im Schrank.
Da habe ich ein paar Kisten
und da schmeiße ich einfach die Sachen rein.
Fertig.
Das war's.
Was ich habe, ist für Rechnung
und sowas, was Stoff ist,
habe ich ein paar Kisten,
die ich einfach in den Schrank
in den Schrank werfe.
Das heißt,
Rechnung und sowas,
was steuerrelevant ist,
dass ich das auch an meinen Steuerberater schicken kann.
Da habe ich in Google Drive,
also in der Google Cloud,
habe ich einen Drive,
was ich freigegeben habe für den Steuerberater.
Und da schiebe ich einfach alles rein,
was der braucht.
Rechnungen, die ich schreibe,
Rechnungen, die ich bekomme,
irgendwelche Auszahlungsbelege.
Da gibt es einen Ordner für Steuern.
Der hat im Endeffekt noch zwei Unterordner,
Einnahmen, Ausgaben.
Und dann so grob,
ein bisschen strukturiert,
Twitch, YouTube, Sponsoring
und solche Geschichten.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen habe ich alles,
was relevant ist für Steuer,
auf Google Drive.
Und den Rest,
wenn ich das in Papierform kriege,
haue ich einfach bei mir in den Schrank
und fertig, aus.
Ja, und ich habe ganz viele Sachen
in meinem IMAP-Postfach,
was man so per Mail kriegt.
Ja, also,
dafür gibt es ja IMAP.
Dass du den Kram,
dass du dich nicht selbst drum kümmern musst.
Wobei die super,
die richtig wichtigen Sachen habe ich hier.
So Einkommensteuererklärung,
Lohnsteuerbescheinigungen und sowas,
das habe ich alle so im Zettel hier im Schrank liegen.
Das kriegt man ja auch noch analog.
Das ist richtig,
das ist richtig.
Ja, wenn du sowas machen willst,
dann ist das sinnvoll.
Aber es ging ja die ganze Zeit um Spielen in der VM.
Wenn man solche Sachen machen möchte,
wie Machine Learning,
ja, dann ist GPU pass-through.
Sinnvoll.
Wobei Machine Learning machst du ja nicht wirklich in der VM,
sondern das machst du ja wahrscheinlich
dann auf deinem Host.
Also auf deinem,
da musst du dann auch nichts pass-throughen.
Und wenn doch, dann schon.
Ja, dann macht es Sinn.
Also wenn du sowas wie Proxmox hast
und willst dort eine VM starten
für Machine Learning Gedöns
und Models lernen und so,
ja, dann schon.
Aber darauf spielt man ja dann auch nicht.
Das macht dann durchaus Sinn, ja.
Dann brauchst du aber von der Grafikkarte
auch die grafische Ausgabe nicht.
Sondern eigentlich nur die Rechenleistung.
Natürlich ist es möglich auf demselben Video,
dabei hat man auch keinen Fenstermodus.
Wie soll das denn funktionieren?
Wenn du eine Grafikkarte durchreichst,
dann hat die nichts mehr mit deinem
Host-Betriebssystem zu tun.
Das heißt, die Bilder kommen erstmal raus
aus dem HDMI-Ausgang.
Da kannst du nur noch so Sachen wie Looking Glass
oder solche Dinger verwenden,
die versuchen, den Frame-Buffer zu kopieren,
rüber auf dein Host-Betrieb,
uns dann anzuzeigen.
Dann hast du aber immer automatisch
1-2 Frame-Delays.
Was bei 240 FPS nicht schlimm ist,
aber okay.
Das sind die einzigen Möglichkeiten,
die es gibt.
Rein logisch gesehen,
wie willst du es anders machen?
Da kann es zigtausend Tutorials geben.
Sag mal, wie willst du es anders machen?
Mir fällt jetzt,
ich will nicht sagen, dass es nichts gibt,
aber mir fällt keine andere Möglichkeit ein.
Wie willst du von einer durchgereichten Grafikkarte
das Bild auf hier,
sagen wir mal hier,
das hier wäre jetzt meine VM
und ich will jetzt hier die Grafikausgabe mir angucken
von der VM.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Entweder schließt du den Monitor an,
schließt du das HDMI-Kabel am gleichen Monitor an
und schaltest den Monitor um,
dass man den Treiber vom Host-Bandits
an den Guest weitergibt.
Ja gut, das ist schön,
aber dann kannst du ja nicht gleichzeitig
dein Host, die VM und dein Host benutzen.
Das ist ja,
das ist genau das gleiche,
wie du nimmst zwei HDMI-Kabel
und schließt zweimal per Monitor an
und schaltest dann irgendwie um
zwischen GPU auf der CPU
und durchgereichte GPU.
Das ist halt,
das ist halt weit davon entfernt,
den Komfort zu haben von,
ich habe hier meine VM
auf dem zweiten Desktop
und kann so dazwischen umschalten.
Beziehungsweise kann auch sagen,
hier guck mal,
ich kopiere einfach mal schnell
ein paar Dinger rüber und so.
Ups,
das war jetzt eine blöde Idee.
Ich will nicht meine Heimat verzeichnen,
ich will nicht meine Heimat verzeichnen
und sie in die VM kopieren.
Ups.
No!
Das war jetzt keine so gute Idee.
Okay, ich glaube,
ich muss,
okay, Close Program.
Sogar der Explorer abgeschissen bei.
Wenn der Guest aber runterfährt,
dann bist du wieder im Host.
Ja, okay,
das kann ich mir,
das kann ich mir vorstellen,
aber das ist ja nicht
gleichzeitig benutzen, ja.
Ja, das ist ja,
da sieht man,
man braucht für alles
und das ist das,
warum ich das nicht mag,
man muss für die einfachsten Sachen
im Vergleich
alles mit irgendwelchen
Workarounds bauen,
die dann noch nicht mal
ansatzweise so gut funktionieren
wie das hier.
Natürlich hat man dann halt
auch die GPU Power in der VM,
aber wozu brauche ich
die GPU Power in der VM,
wenn ich einfach
das Setup machen kann,
was den vollen Komfort bietet,
die volle GPU Power dort hat,
wo ich es brauche
und mehr oder weniger
zu 99% Linux so benutzen kann
mit allem,
was es bietet
und wofür es gut ist.
Also,
deswegen,
ich persönlich bin der Meinung,
das beste Setup
und das produktivste Setup
ist immer noch
Windows als Host
und eine ordentliche VM
auch mit ordentlichen Ressourcen
auf dem zweiten Desktop.
Ich meine,
machen kann es jeder,
wie er will.
Ich für meinen Teil
finde das am besten.
Was habt ihr so
auf eurem Heim-Server laufen?
Aktuell noch Unraid
und es bleibt es wahrscheinlich
auch erstmal,
aber wirklich glücklich bin ich
mit keiner Lösung.
Vielleicht mache ich mir einfach
wieder einen Debian drauf,
wie früher.
Welche VM-Software?
Ich benutze vor allem
eine Workstation.
Ja,
Debian 12.1 ist raus.
Okay,
das ging aber schnell
für Debian-Verhältnisse,
oder?
Kam Debian 12 nicht erst
vor einem Monat raus?
Oder vor zwei Wochen
oder so?
Ja,
das ist eine gute Variante.
Das kannst du machen.
CPU,
also
die Grafikkarte
von der CPU
für Host
und die GPU
in die VM.
Da hast du aber immer noch
das Problem,
du musst die grafischen Ausgaben
irgendwie am Monitor,
irgendwie zum Monitor
hinbringen.
Das heißt,
du kannst zum Beispiel
zwei Kabel,
einen grafischen Monitor
und dann umschalten
am Monitor.
Das geht.
Das ist alles
durchaus mit
verdrehtbarem Aufwand,
aber halt
trotzdem nicht ganz so
komfortabel wie einfach
den Desktop switchen.
Dafür hast du volle
Grafik-Power.
Dann ist halt die Frage,
wie bekommst du zum Beispiel
deine,
deine Maus und Tastatur
ordentlich rein?
Ah ja,
gut,
auch mit irgendwelchen
Workarounds.
Ja.
89 Bugfixes.
Wenn man sich mal überlegt,
wie viel Software in Debian
drin ist,
sind 89 Bugfixes
eigentlich gar nicht mal
so viel.
Hält sich,
hält sich in Grenzen.
Lass uns mal kurz gucken,
die aktuellen GitHub,
die Shit,
die Shit-Hub-Trends.
AI.
Oh ne,
es geht wieder los,
Leute.
AI.
Ich weiß nicht,
was es sein soll,
ehrlich gesagt.
Fast and Memory Efficient
Exact Attention.
Flash...
Hä?
Was soll das?
Was soll das sein?
Ah ja.
Ah,
GPT.
Okay.
AI.
Hätte,
hätte man auch
hier reinschreiben können.
AI.
LazyVim.
NeoVim-Config.
Okay.
AI.
Web-Applications
mit Rust.
Pass mal auf.
Lass mal gucken,
wie eklig das aussieht.
Du hast schon
Only-Fans-Bots
angetextet.
Let's go.
Man muss sich
jetzt überlegen.
Ich,
ich gebe euch
jetzt mal einen Ratschlag.
Bei der Auswahl von Frameworks,
beziehungsweise,
nein, nicht,
nicht bei der Auswahl von Frameworks,
beim Lesen
von GitHub Readmes.
Und zwar,
ihr müsst immer
von folgendem Fall ausgehen.
Die Sachen,
die euch
in Readmes
gezeigt werden,
das sind,
also,
davon solltet ihr
ausgehen,
das ist
der bestmögliche Fall
bestmöglich
dargestellt.
Das heißt,
wenn der schon
eklig aussieht,
dann könnt ihr
von ausgehen
in der praktischen
Anwendung
ist es noch
ekliger.
Ja,
das hier geht
vollkommen klar
von der Optik
noch.
Aber,
man sieht schon,
man sieht schon
so ein bisschen
die Ekligkeiten
der Rust-Syntaxe
an manchen Stellen.
Warum benutzt du
freiwillig
Windows 11?
Ja,
was ist die Alternative?
Windows 10 oder
Windows XP?
Was,
was soll,
was soll die Alternative sein?
Ne,
ne,
ach so,
ja,
warum ich Windows 11 benutze,
ist ganz einfach,
deswegen,
weil meine CPU nur
gescheit supportet wird
unter Windows 11.
Das ist der Grund.
Da sag ich gleich was zu.
Haben wir uns schon anguckt,
AI,
China-Chinesen-AI.
Ich hab keine Ahnung,
was das sein soll,
Leute.
Mhm,
mhm,
naja,
alles klar,
obviously,
Google,
Google Translate.
Nicht auf Russisch,
alter.
Moment,
wie konnte man nochmal
Webseiten translaten?
Ging das nicht hier oben
irgendwie drüber?
Hm,
es gab doch
Translate,
Websites,
genau.
Äh,
von Sprache erkennen,
nein,
das ist Frosch.
Wunder!
Oh,
okay,
geil.
Du wirst dich hier
selber
decken wollen.
Sehr gut.
Freut mich.
Also,
die
auf
confrontieren
mich
nicht was das für eine um was es geht wahrscheinlich ist es nicht nachdem es
sich anhört aber es trennt auf jeden fall schon mal mit 16.000 github-stern
ei lockt ok net data tabby naja so spannend ist es jetzt nicht was die
woche trendet 80 prozent wieder schauen wir noch mal kurz was in der net welt zu
trendet die woche to do ab da siehst du in der net welt war nichts los wenn eine
to do app trendet auf github das ist der asp.net erfinder oder ja ja
glaube ich guck hier asp.net team oder zumindest einer mit erfinder von asp.net
core okay das sind wahrscheinlich quasi so halb offizielle samples deswegen hat
das so viele so viele sterne web api sharp wx
damals
ok china chinesen zeug china chinesen zeug machine learning hex editor for china chinesen chat app
keine ahnung was das sein soll kerberos aha power toys lean algorithmic trade engine bestimmt ai
zeug material design für wpf ja weil wpf outdated overrated she baited alter hässlicher kram ist
plotting library im hau mai monke erster menu ui das haben wir schon angeguckt
ich fand es vor ne idee ganz cool aber uns hat mich zu sehr am ende kürze
erinnert mix reality unity zeug spain game weil ich sehr cool für das in dem
trendet auch in spiel was gar nicht übel aussah also pixel grafikmäßig muss man
was muss man was trinken kratzen im hals so dann haben wir in audio tatsächlich
Tatsächlich, das habe ich schon benutzt.
Das ist eine nice Audio-Library.
Damit haben wir mal eine China-Chinesen-Kamera
verbunden mit einer Windows-Forms-App,
wo man Two-Way-Audio mitmachen konnte.
Wir haben in irgendeinem Stream gemacht,
ich erinnere mich noch.
Two-Way-Audio von so einer China-Chinesen-Kamera
zu einer Windows-App.
Nicht, weil ich es irgendwie groß verwenden wollte,
sondern weil ich wissen wollte, wie es geht.
Escape vom Tarkov.
Offline-Koop.
Okay.
Power-Shell.
Wire-Head.
Ah, das ist...
Da haben wir doch letztens das Video zugeguckt.
Cool, dass das trendet.
Da haben wir letztens das Video noch zugeguckt.
Das ist der Typ, der quasi die Wire-Logik
in Terraria neu gebaut hat,
damit er einen Computer in Terraria bauen konnte.
Ja, das trendet auch.
Terraria-Mods.
View-Face-Core.
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Ich weiß nicht, was ist das?
Face-Recognition.
Ja, das ist klar.
Da stehen die Chinesen drauf.
Automatische Kamera-Footage-Auswertung
und Bilder-Gesichtserkennung.
Typisches China-Chinesen-Thema.
Wobei man sagen muss,
da ist es vielleicht besonders verbreitet,
aber für alle anderen ist es natürlich auch praktisch,
wenn es die eigenen Kameras sind.
So, also, ich wollte doch hier was zu sagen.
Wo ist die Frage mit dem...
Hier.
Wie steht dein Arbeitgeber zu deiner Nebentätigkeit?
Also, was der dazu denkt, weiß ich nicht.
Er weiß es, auf jeden Fall.
Er wusste es schon, bevor ich mich dort beworben habe,
weil es stand ja sogar in meiner Bewerbung drin.
Also, bei mir können sie sich echt nicht beschweren.
Wir wussten davon nichts.
Es stand in meiner Bewerbung drin
und wir haben im Vorstellungsgespräch
sogar noch drüber gesprochen.
Und wir haben uns sogar einen GitHub-Repo angeguckt
mit einem Projekt drin, wo wir im Stream-Tranit
teilweise schon mitentwickelt haben.
Also, ganz ehrlich,
also, da kann...
Ich weiß nicht, was sie davon denken,
aber sie scheinen ja nichts dagegen gehabt zu haben.
Hast du das Gefühl,
dass das deine Karriere behindern könnte?
Muss man sich für einen nehmen?
Ja, immer vom Arbeitgeber...
Das stimmt.
Wobei die Sache die ist,
sie können so ohne weiteres nichts dagegen sagen.
Und ich glaube, es ist noch komplizierter,
wenn du die Nebentätigkeit schon machst,
bevor du dort angefangen hast
und wenn es halt auch gar nichts damit zu tun hat.
Ja, muss man.
Man muss es immer dort bekannt geben.
Aber bei mir können sie sich aber wirklich nicht beschweren,
dass sie es nicht gewusst haben.
Die wussten das schon,
bevor ich in der Bewerbung sogar selbst stand,
schon drin.
Also, wenn da einer sagt, so nach dem Motto,
ach, Max, hättest du mal früher was gesagt,
sag ich, ich hab so früh wie irgendwie möglich
ist davon was gesagt.
Hast du das Gefühl, dass du deine Karriere behindern könnte?
Also,
die Frage muss man anders stellen.
Die muss man zweifeln.
Die muss man doppelt stellen.
Und zwar,
also, die Frage muss ich auf zwei Arten interpretieren.
Hast du das Gefühl, dass deine Karriere behindert werden könnte?
Nein, hab ich nicht,
weil ich hab nicht vor, Karriere zu machen.
Wenn du fragen würdest,
hast du das Gefühl,
ob das das deine, falls ich es machen wollte,
möchte, ja,
Karriere behindern könnte,
dann müsste ich sagen, ja, vielleicht.
Das hab ich übrigens auch letztens,
wo wir grad dabei sind,
genau das Thema hab ich doch sogar angesprochen.
Weiß ich nicht, hast du das Video hier geguckt?
Da rede ich ja unter anderem genau über sowas.
Also, ja, theoretisch,
wenn ich Karriere machen wollen würde,
könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das ab einer gewissen Stufe
problematisch wäre,
allerdings weniger die Nebentätigkeit selbst,
sondern,
dass ich nur vier Tage die Woche arbeite.
Was von wegen der Nebentätigkeit kommt.
Ja, vielleicht,
aber für mich, nö.
Ich hab auch, ihr wisst ja,
ich hab auch keine Ambition,
was irgendwie Karriere machen angeht.
Muss man ja auch nicht,
weil man verdient, wenn man Techniker ist,
beziehungsweise, nenn das mal IT-Spezialist,
Experte-Typ halt,
der was kann, was halbwegs gefragt ist,
verdient man genug Kohle,
ohne dass man irgendwie den krassen Karriere-Crime machen muss.
Also ohne, dass ich jetzt sagen würde,
oh, ich will noch irgendwie mal ein bisschen
Projektmanagement machen, oder sowas.
Geh mal bloß fort.
Ich glaube, das ist das Schlimmste, was ich mir vorstellen könnte,
noch nebenbei Projektmanagement mitmachen zu wollen.
Projektmanagement ist,
es gibt so zwei Sachen, da kriegst du immer Anschiss.
Das ist,
wenn du Projektmanager bist, kriegst du immer Anschiss von den Leuten,
die mitarbeiten im Projekt,
und von den Leuten, die das Projekt quasi,
äh, ownen,
und Budgetplanung machen.
Und wenn du Teamleiter bist, kriegst du immer Anschiss von deinem Team,
und, äh, den Leuten oben drüber.
Das sind zwei Positionen, die würde ich nie, eben,
im Leben machen wollen.
Ja.
Natürlich, es könnte auch noch sein,
irgendwie hab ich, muss ich auch was trinken.
So.
Und,
dann hast du natürlich noch die Möglichkeit,
hey,
wenn du in deinem,
in deiner Nebentätigkeit,
bei, beispielsweise, ich auf YouTube,
oder hier im, im Stream,
wenn ich dort Sachen machen würde,
die irgendwie entgegen dem sind,
was meinem Arbeitgeber gefällt, ja?
Also, also erstens, erstens,
bei mir ist das eh kein Problem.
Also, also erstens, erstens, bei mir ist das eh kein Problem.
Weil niemand weiß, wo ich arbeite.
Das heißt, da kann der Arbeitgeber auch nicht argumentieren,
Max, du sagst in deinem Stream, was,
was gegen die Firmenwerte wäre, oder irgendwie sowas.
Weil,
solange es keiner zusammenbringt,
kann man sich da auch nicht beschweren.
Das weiß vielleicht der, aber,
da kann kein, das mögen vielleicht dort ein paar Leute
herstellen können, diesen Zusammenhang, aber,
es kann niemand den Zusammenhang sonst herstellen,
weil,
es weiß schlicht und ergreifend keiner.
Und da kann man auch nicht argumentieren,
ah, das würde uns irgendwie schaden.
Wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise,
sagen würde, hier, ich arbeite bei der Deutschen Bank,
was, was ich nicht mache, ja, sag nur,
äh, und ich würde jetzt öffentlich sagen,
ah, habt ihr schon die letzte Kampagne gesehen,
die die Deutsche Bank macht, mit,
keine Ahnung, Jan Ullrich?
Ich hab keinen Schimmer, ob die sowas machen, und,
alter, der Typ, der sagt übelst, und, äh,
die bescheißen nur die Leute und so.
Also mal angenommen, wenn ich mich dann so positionieren würde,
gegen meinen Arbeitgeber, da könnten die sicherlich was dagegen sagen,
wobei ich Jan Ullrich übelst, also,
naja,
ich hab halt früher viel Radsport geguckt,
auch zu den Zeiten so 1997, so war das ja mega Hype,
ich find ja Jan Ullrich eigentlich ganz nice,
ähm,
in letzten Jahren, naja, sagen wir mal so,
vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt das Vorbild gewesen,
aber es war ja nur ein Beispiel.
So, das ist sicherlich was, wo ein Arbeitgeber was dagegen sagen könnte,
aber bei mir, und, äh, bei mir, bei mir gibt's das Problem nicht,
weil es weiß halt keiner, wo ich arbeite.
Außer ein paar Leute dort, was aber nicht wild ist, weil,
wenn jemand argumentieren könnte, ja, aber,
wenn du öffentlich dann was dazu sagst,
dann bringen das die Leute ja zusammen und das schadet uns,
das schadet halt nix, weil's keiner weiß.
Ich merk übrigens, dass ich mega alt bin,
ich hab letztens nachgeguckt, Jan Ullrich ist glaub ich 48 oder so mittlerweile.
49, alter!
Da, da merk ich, dass ich übelst alt bin.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, da hab ich eben 1997 und so,
hab ich mit meinem Opa Tour de France geguckt, Jan Ullrich, alle voll, voll gehypt,
da war ich, da war ich klein noch, da war ich so ein kleiner Hüpfer, 1997 war ich,
2013, hä?
13, Jan Ullrich war da, keine Ahnung, 23 oder so.
Krass, oder?
Das richtig, da merkt man mal, wie richtig Ultra-Boomer man mittlerweile ist.
Heftig.
Ja, so, so viel, so viel dazu.
Was für einen Kühler hast du?
Ganz einfach, pass mal auf,
macht mal Chat, Chat, Ausrufezeichen,
äh, es ist Ausrufezeichen PC,
ja, Ausrufezeichen PC ist es.
Ja, da kommt ihr, da kommt ihr auf die Zusammenstellung von meinem aktuellen Rechner
und ich habe als Lüfter eine Art Arctic Liquid Freezer Wasserkühler.
RGB natürlich, was sonst?
Das ist mein, das ist mein Lüfter, quasi.
Erste Mal, dass ich eine Wasserkühlung hab und ich muss sagen, bis jetzt, mega nice,
macht überhaupt keine Probleme, alles gut.
Alles pog.
Ja, wurde umbenannt, schon vor einer Weile.
Wie sieht es, wie sieht es denn eigentlich aus mit KI und IT, wie jetzt, wie soll es da aussehen?
Das ist ein immer gefragteres Feld.
Und das ist ein Trend, der geht,
der wird vielleicht für viele noch nicht so relevant sein, aber der geht auf jeden Fall
an keinem, also an keinem ernstzunehmenden IT-Führungskreis vorbei.
Sich da nicht ein bisschen Gedanken drüber zu machen, was das bedeuten könnte für das, für das eigene Unternehmen.
An vielen geht es noch ein bisschen vorbei, aber ich glaube, auf dem Radar haben es viele.
Gibt es eigentlich Source Code in Kyrillisch wahrscheinlich?
Die Franzosen, wollte ich gerade sagen, die Franzosen schreiben auch gerne französische Variablen an.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, ich sehe das ja teilweise sogar für Leute, die in der Berufsschule oder teilweise sogar an der Uni noch,
aber eher Berufsschule, irgendwelche Übungsprogramme programmieren und das heißt dann wirklich,
da gibt es dann wirklich Variablen, die heißen Nummer oder Zehn.
Oder Zähler und sowas.
Da kriege ich immer Anfälle, wenn ich das sehe.
Schreibt den Kram halt in Englisch und fertig ist.
Dann lernt man auch gleich das ordentlich zu benennen alles.
Außerdem, die eigentliche Fifehead-Variante ist doch nicht, also, das ist, das ist Noob.
Der Nächste schreibt Counter, der Advancedere schreibt C, CNT und der Pro schreibt einfach nur noch C.
Easy.
Wird einfach immer mal abgekürzt.
Wobei ich ja persönlich das hier nicht verkehrt finde.
Da weiß man wenigstens, was gemeint ist.
Und irgendwann haben die Leute gar keinen Bock mehr und benutzen nur noch Autocomplete.
Dann heißt alles nur noch I oder N.
Oder Z.
Ich glaube, I, N und Z sind die Default-Autocomplete-Dinger, wenn du Nested-Schleifen machst.
Der hat Ärger vor...
Ja gut, aber der hat ja auch öffentlich gesagt, der arbeitet bei Facebook und hat sich dazu geäußert.
Dann ist es so, dann ist ja direkt die Verbindung herstellbar.
Ist ja bei mir nicht.
Habt ihr gestern auch Probleme?
Nö.
Für Mitbewerber bin ich auch nicht tätig.
Nö, bin ich nicht.
Ich bin für mich tätig.
Das Ding ist, ich würde nebenbei einfach gerne eigene Projekte umsetzen im SARS-Umfeld.
Ich habe nur die...
Wieso?
Wenn du eigene Projekte machst, ist es für den Arbeitgeber doch extrem pog.
Dann hast du Ahnung von was, was du auf der Arbeit benutzen kannst.
Wo ist das Problem, eigene Projekte umzusetzen?
Das sehe ich überhaupt kein Ding, überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich meine, man kann es nicht.
Ich meine, man kann es nie ausschließen, dass es irgendwelche pepege Arbeitgeber, pepege Chefs gibt.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wo ist das...
Da würde ich überhaupt kein Problem dabei sehen.
Da lernst du ja auch was, was dir im Job was bringen kann.
Ohne dass die irgendwelche Schulungen bezahlen müssten oder du Einarbeitung bräuchtest und erstmal ein paar Wochen nichts machen kannst.
Also das würde ich eher von Vorteil sehen, wenn Leute sowas machen möchten.
Man weiß nie, wie manche Arbeitgeber ticken.
Aber da sehe ich jetzt gar kein Problem.
So lange gültig.
Gleich true, genau.
Am besten noch in einer if-Schleife.
if-Schleife ist eh einfach das Beste.
Wir sollten nur noch in if-Schleifen programmieren.
Sprechende Variablenamen ist aber dann schon sinnvoll.
Ja, Moment.
Du brauchst sprechende Variablenamen ja nur, wenn es einfacher zu lesen sein soll.
Also sprich einfacher zu debuggen soll.
Und debuggen musst du nur, wenn du was falsch gemacht hast.
Wenn du instant immer perfekt funktionierenden, hundertprozentig durchdachte Sachen programmierst, die einfach instant funktionieren, dann kannst du schreiben, wie du willst.
Dann brauchst du auch keine Doku und Tests.
Einfach das Beste.
Einfach immer fehlerfrei programmieren und du hast überhaupt keine Probleme mehr.
Du hast alle Probleme gelöst, instant.
Easy.
Ja, sag ich doch.
Einfach keine Fehler programmieren.
So wie wir das im Stream auch immer machen.
Es, es...
Also bei mir im Stream ist es prinzipiell ja immer so.
Sobald es kompiliert, funktioniert es auch hundertprozentig.
Hat man ja schon oft gesehen.
Ja, siehste?
Gut, gut, dass ihr hier gewesen seid und das gehört habt.
Madgirl.
Ist das etwa diese Fake-Webseite, die uns sagen möchte, dass es keine if-Schleifen gibt?
Aha.
Die ganzen Noobs wieder alle keine Ahnung haben sie.
Richtig.
Genau.
Das, deswegen, dass es keine Bugs gibt, sieht man auch einfach hier dran.
Guck.
Es ist offensichtlich, dass es keine Bugs gibt.
Sonst hätte ich nicht, sonst hätte ich nicht so viele Tickets schon schließen müssen.
Es sind immerhin mehr Tickets closed als offen.
Multiple Cars ist kein Bug.
Das ist eine Designentscheidung.
Das ist ein, das ist eindeutig Anwendungsfehler.
Äh, Absicht.
Absicht, ich will, dass die Leute sich nicht aussperren.
Warum sollte man Charging vorher absicht?
Äh, neue Home Assistant Version.
Äh, liegt dein Home Assistant nicht an meinem Addon?
Äh, Post Commands failing mit 403.
Anwenderfehler.
Ähm.
Prinzipiell überhaupt kein Problem an der Software.
Es wird echt mal Zeit.
Ich muss, ich muss unbedingt das Ding überarbeiten.
Weil spätestens, wenn ich mein Home Assistant mal upgradee, dann wird er wahrscheinlich auch kaputt gehen.
Weil die irgendwas geändert haben an ihrem Addon.
Einlese, Zeug.
So, es wird Zeit für Fiat Champ Version 2.
Wobei wir sind schon bei Version 3 eigentlich.
Also Version 4.
Fiat Champ 4.0.
Wobei ich das Ding nicht neu bauen werde.
Aber, aber ein bisschen erweitern.
Ich habe mir auch schon überlegt, wie man es am besten macht.
Zum Beispiel, muss ich endlich einbauen, dass mehrere Fahrzeuge unterstützt werden, wenn man sie von unterschiedlichen Herstellern hat.
Aktuell kannst du mehrere Autos von Fiat haben.
Aber gerade bei den Amis.
Die haben irgendeine Dotter.
Die haben irgendeinen Dodge Truck und noch einen Fiat.
Und das funktioniert mit dem Addon nicht.
Und du kannst das Addon auch nicht mehrfach installieren.
Also du kriegst entweder nur deinen Dodge Truck oder deinen Fiat rein.
Nicht beides.
Wenn du zwei Dodge Trucks hättest, dann würdest du sie reinkriegen.
Oder zwei Fiats.
Aber nicht zwei unterschiedliche Hersteller.
Ja, das muss gefixt werden noch.
Und auch das Handling mit den MQTT-Messages und so.
Das ist alles nicht schön gemacht.
Und die Commands.
Das, das, das muss.
Und auch die Fehlermeldung.
Also ich müsste echt mal.
Das grundsätzlich überarbeiten mit dem, was ich gelernt habe aus der ersten Version.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Okay, Chat gehen.
Viel geschwätzt.
Lasst uns mal gucken.
Können wir uns doch irgendwann die YouTube-Videos anschauen?
Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
How JavaScript ruined the Web.
I seriously almost just got hacked.
Okay, das ist Gbait.
Das ist garantiert Gbait.
So schnell wird dein Fahrrad.
Das gucken wir jetzt mal als erstes.
Ich glaube, ich weiß nämlich, worum es geht.
Dass ein niederländischer Fahrradhersteller.
Pleite ist.
Und das Fahrrad um zum Einstellen von der Lichthelligkeit und sowas eine App braucht.
Und die App wird bald nicht mehr funktionieren, weil die Server abgeschaltet werden.
Also auf die Idee muss man erst mal kommen.
Ein Fahrrad, ein E-Fahrrad, also ein Elektrofahrrad so abhängig zu machen von Cloud-Infrastruktur.
Ja.
Genau.
Ja, die meine ich.
Für einen Rewrite müsstest du gehyptere Sprachen.
Nee, das macht nichts.
Dass ich wenige Leute finde, die mit entwickeln.
Also um gehypt zu sein, müsste ich es mal mindestens in Rust entwickeln, oder?
Was wäre denn, Max, was wäre denn noch eine Möglichkeit?
Rewrite in Rust?
Was ist denn sonst noch richtig gehypt aktuell?
Mein Python geht immer.
Go vielleicht ein bisschen.
Aber wenn ich in Python mache, dann könnte ich auch die direkte Home Assistant Integration bauen.
Und der Grund, warum ich es nicht in Python mache, ist, weil ich nicht so der Python-Hackerman bin.
Also Go.
Go in Rust vielleicht, ja.
JavaScript, natürlich.
Aber das ist alles so viel ekliger darin zu entwickeln, als in C Sharp.
Wobei, Go geht noch irgendwo.
E++.
Beste Idee, ja.
Fängt ja schon damit an, dass die C++-Standard-Library,
keinen, es kommt ja der Hit,
die C++-Standard-Library hat keinen Web-Client.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
C++-Standard-Lib hat keinen HTTP-Client.
Ne, ne, wir fangen jetzt nicht davon an.
Wisst ihr, bei C++ diskutieren sie dann darüber, ja, wir können keinen Web-Client machen,
weil wir haben ja keine Netzwerke.
Kein Netzwerk-Stack.
Und Netzwerk-Stack können wir nicht machen, weil wir auch Plattformen unterstützen,
die low-level sind.
Andere Sprachen sagen einfach, okay, wir machen das trotzdem.
Und Sprachen, die es nicht supporten, dann gibt es halt eine no-supported-Exception.
Und fertig, aus.
Könnte man in C++ auch machen, ja.
Aber nein.
Man sagt lieber, nee, machen wir erst gar nicht.
So, also, gucken wir uns mal das an mit dem Fahrrad.
Gucken, ob es da neue Erkenntnisse dazu gibt.
Guck mal hier, ich fahr hier auf meinem Rad.
Ich hab jetzt eigentlich gedacht,
dass das, ähm,
they see me rollin'.
Das hätte jetzt einfach zu gut gepasst.
Guck mal hier, ich fahr hier auf meinem Rad.
Und jetzt stellt euch mal vor, der Hersteller von meinem Fahrrad geht pleite.
Ein bisschen Kleingeld, man.
Ist ja egal, hat ja mit deinem Fahrrad nichts zu tun, denkt ihr.
Nee, so ist das nicht.
Zumindest, wenn mein Fahrrad von VanMoof wäre.
Ja, okay, war klar, dass das kommt.
Viele Funktionen bei diesen ziemlich beliebten Fahrrädern funktionieren nur,
wenn die VanMoof-Server laufen.
Ich dachte, es heißt Move,
weil das ein Witz auf Movement ist.
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht.
Kann man so ein Fahrrad gar nicht mehr benutzen,
wenn die Server ausgeschaltet sind.
Nun hat VanMoof Insolvenz angemeldet.
Es weiß also niemand, wie das mit den Servern weitergeht.
Man muss sich das echt mal vorstellen, gell?
Man braucht eine Cloud für sein Fahrrad.
Alter, 2023, das ist einfach so pepega in vielen Bereichen.
Für sein scheiß Fahrrad eine Cloud-Anbindung.
Es stimmt nicht so ganz.
Es stimmt nicht so ganz, du kannst das Fahrrad noch benutzen.
Aber du kannst halt so Sachen wie Lichthelligkeit und Entsperren und so nicht mehr benutzen.
Und jetzt passt mal auf, wisst ihr warum nicht?
Viel besser.
Es ist nicht so, als würde es offline nicht funktionieren.
Nein, nein.
Die eigentliche Kommunikation zwischen Fahrrad und App funktioniert über Bluetooth.
Aber die App braucht beim Start eine Verbindung zum Cloud-Server,
zum Entschlüsseln des Bluetooth-Keys.
Also es macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Man könnte das ohne Probleme auf dem Smartphone speichern.
Aber nein, will man nicht, weil man möchte ja Vendor-Login machen,
um des Vendor-Login-Willens.
Übrigens, es gibt schon Abhilfe.
Ich glaube, das wird er auch in dem Video zeigen.
Es gibt schon Abhilfe.
Es gibt eine Konkurrenz-App, die das versucht nachzubauen.
Und es gibt einen Key Extractor.
Auf GitHub.
Der Funmove Encryption Key Exporter.
Da kann man sein Bike danach auch weiter benutzen.
Großartig.io.
Beste, beste Domain.
Das Problem dabei ist nur, dass der 0815 weniger technikaffine E-Bike Benutzer,
was es ja durchaus geben kann,
schon ein wenig überfordert ist mit der Anleitung.
Allein schon, dass der Docker Compose, der weiß noch nicht mal, was Docker überhaupt ist.
Ja.
Aber gut, dass es das gibt.
Okay.
Drücken wir uns das Video an.
... wenn die Server abgeschaltet werden?
Monka Toss Toss Toss.
Und wie kann es eigentlich sein, dass man sich was kauft, also zum Beispiel ein Fahrrad,
und dann darauf keinen Zugriff mehr hat, nur weil der Hersteller pleite geht?
Tja.
Willkommen in 2023.
Ich find's auch kacke.
Skandal!
Wir haben uns mal einen von Move S1 und S3 besorgt und gucken, was wir damit ohne herstellen.
Muss er nicht selbst hosten, er kann die Webseite benutzen.
Okay.
Wenn es rein webbasiert ist...
Du brauchst einen Windows-Rechner mit Bluetooth wahrscheinlich, machst Web-Bluetooth, oder?
Ja, dann ist es easy.
Dann ist es tatsächlich easy.
Dann habe ich das falsch verstanden.
Okay.
Ja, dann ist es okay.
Wenn das über die Webseite, dann ist es kein Problem.
Das kriegt wahrscheinlich jeder hin.
Das war bei BMW, glaube ich, mit der Sitzheizung im Auto, ja.
Aber das ist doch mittlerweile gang und gäbe, dass die Technik im Auto mehr hergibt, als...
als eingeschaltet ist.
Ich würde sagen, das ist...
Das ist eigentlich fast... fast normal.
... Besteller Server überhaupt noch anfangen können.
Bleibt dran.
Toss.
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Ja, ist ja gut, ey.
Das Intro, Alter.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von 3CX.
Wenn ich jetzt sagen würde...
Also, das hier ist echt mal wieder so eine Story, die vor 10 Jahren einfach komplett absurde Science-Fiction gewesen wäre.
Ja, das stimmt.
Die einem niemand geglaubt hätte.
Und die Story geht so.
Besitzt man ein Elektrofahrrad des Herstellers von MOV, kann das sein, dass man das Teil in Zukunft nicht mehr benutzen kann, weil der Hersteller nämlich vor ein paar Tagen Insolvenz angemeldet hat.
Und eigentlich ist das ja erstmal total irrelevant für das mechanische Objekt Fahrrad.
Denkt man, denkt man, ja.
Das Rad bleibt ja ein Rad, egal was mit dem Hersteller passiert.
Aber von MOV-Rädern funktionieren erst, wenn man sie über eine Smartphone-App aktiviert hat.
Mit der App kann man dann nicht nur Sachen wie die Automatikschaltung oder...
...die Beleuchtung einstellen, sondern damit öffnet man auch das Schloss bzw. schaltet die mechanische Wegfahrsperre aus.
Das war damals, als die ersten von MOV-Räder rauskamen, ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal.
Klingt ja auch erstmal nice.
Sobald man mit dem eigenen Telefon in die Nähe des Fahrrads kommt, öffnet es sich.
Geht man weg, schließt es sich ab.
Ja, super.
Ja, und würde das alles einfach nur über die App und unverschlüsseltes Bluetooth funktionieren, wäre das ja zumindest temporär kein Problem, wenn von MOV die Server abstellt.
Weil die App liegt ja in den App-Stores von Apple.
Ja.
Apple und Google, dafür braucht man ja die von MOV-Server eigentlich nicht.
Also zumindest, solange die Smartphone-Betriebssysteme die App noch unterstützen.
Nun ist es aber so, dass die Bluetooth-Verbindung bei...
Ähm, wisst ihr, was mir dabei auffällt?
Also, du brauchst die App, um dein Fahrrad aufzuschließen.
Klingt ja erstmal nach einer sinnvollen Idee und klingt auch erstmal so, als würde das dazu führen, dass jemand sich das zweimal überlegt, das Fahrrad zu klauen.
Aber das Fahrrad muss ja für den Fall der Fälle, dass dein Handy kaputt geht, du dein Passwort vergisst oder was auch immer...
Eine Möglichkeit des Resets bieten, um es neu zu pairen.
Und dann kann man doch das Fahrrad einfach unter den Arm nehmen, wegtragen und Werksreset machen und neu pairen, oder?
Na gut, vielleicht, wenn das...
Vielleicht wird dann der Standort angezeigt oder irgendwas oder...
Ich weiß nicht, wie die das dagegen...
Ja, okay, ich weiß nicht, wie sie das gemacht haben, ja.
Aber du kriegst dann bestimmt eine Nachricht.
Irgendwie werden sie sich dafür schon was ausgedacht haben.
... noch unterstützen.
Nun ist es aber so, dass die Bluetooth-Verbindung bei FANMOV grundsätzlich verschlüsselt ist.
Die App holt sich bei jeder Nutzung vom FANMOV-Server einen digitalen Schlüssel ab.
Ja, das ist das Problem.
Und kommt der nicht, weil die Server down sind, kann man sich auf den Kopf stellen.
Dann lässt sich das Smartphone nicht mehr mit dem Fahrrad verbinden.
Das heißt, man kann nichts mehr einstellen, aufschließen und einschalten kann man auch nicht mehr.
Es scheint zwar so zu sein, dass die Keys für eine Zeit auf dem Handy gespeichert werden, aber definitiv nicht für ewig.
Und wenn das Handy kaputt geht, ist natürlich sowieso Feuer ab.
Ja, und eine wirklich einfach zu bedienende Alternative gibt es bislang nur für die FANMOV-Modelle der Dreier-Serie, also S3, X3.
Da hat die Konkurrenzfirma Cowboy eine Alternativ-App für Android- und iOS-Smartphones rausgebracht.
Die holt sich die Sicherheitsschlüssel vom FANMOV-Server, speichert die auf dem Telefon und bildet dann auch die Grundfunktionen der FANMOV-Original-App nach.
Da ist man dann erstmal auf der sicheren Seite und kann das Rad auch weiter per App steuern.
Aber es geht immer noch über die Cowboy-Server dann, oder wie?
Kann auch, wenn die FANMOV-Server abgeschaltet werden.
Ja, okay, es speichert lokal auf dem Handy.
Und wir haben uns hier mal so ein S1 und S3 hingestellt und gucken jetzt mal, was passiert denn eigentlich, wenn man nicht die Hersteller-App benutzt.
Kommt man da trotzdem irgendwie dran?
Wir haben die Bikey-App ausprobiert. Funktioniert problemlos mit dem S3.
Man kann damit zwar nicht komplett alle Einstellungen der Original-FANMOV-App vornehmen, also zum Beispiel ganz detailliert die Schaltstufen.
Aber die wichtigsten Dinge klappen.
Also vor allem Fahrrad entsperren.
Unterstützung, zum Beispiel ganz detailliert die Schaltstufen.
Stattdessen, eine MAC-Adresse wurde ausgeblendet. Wurde die wirklich komplett ausgeblendet?
Schauen wir mal, ob der Cutter...
Ha!
Ha! Ich hab's doch gesehen!
Leaked!
Chat, Fahrrad übernehmen, direkt, let's go!
Seid ihr schon drin, ja?
Nee, nicht schlimm, passiert wahrscheinlich einfach gar nichts.
Mal gucken, ob das schon jemand in den Comments geschrieben hat, dass man die MACs sehen kann.
Die Leute freuen sich immer wahnsinnig, wenn sie sowas finden.
MAC.
Nee, anscheinend nicht, okay.
Hat anscheinend niemand entdeckt.
Aber die wichtigsten Dinge klappen.
Also vor allem Fahrrad entsperren, Unterstützungsstufen einstellen und natürlich am allerwichtigsten den Hupen-Sound festlegen.
Ganz wichtig!
Zum Einloggen braucht man dann tatsächlich nicht mehr das FANMOV-Login und Passwort, sondern sagt einfach Import Key,
wählt die lokal gespeicherte Datei aus und zack.
Ist man mit dem Fahrrad verbunden.
Ziemlich cool.
Beim S1 konnten wir mit der Bikey-App nur den Sicherheitsschlüssel sichern, aber leider nicht das Rad bedienen oder entsperren.
Cowboy hat schon angekündigt, demnächst auch FANMOV-Fahrräder der S5-X5-Serie zu unterstützen.
Wer allerdings einen FANMOV, der einer, zweier oder vierer Serie hat, schaut zurzeit in die Röhre.
Was man aber unbedingt schon mal machen sollte, wenn man so ein FANMOV-Rad hat,
mit dem entspannten Key-Exporter von Justus Dietrich und Marius Angelmann, einmal den Schlüssel fürs eigene Rad vom FANMOV-Login,
ja, solange das noch geht.
Womöglich wird dann noch Software kommen, die die FANMOV-App-Funktionalität nachbildet
und mit lokal auf dem Telefon gespeicherten Keys funktioniert.
Was man ebenfalls unbedingt machen sollte, solange die Server noch aktiv sind,
den manuellen Fahrrad-Einschalt-Code aktivieren.
Damit kann man nämlich mit so Morse-Code-artigen Tasten drücken, das Rad entsperren.
Das geht dann künftig auch ohne gekoppeltes Handy.
Macht man das aber alles nicht und wartet einfach ab,
und FANMOV stellt die Server aus,
ja, dann kann man im schlimmsten Fall wirklich nichts mehr mit dem Rad anfangen.
Obendrein gibt es aber auch noch andere Risiken.
Da habe ich mal Stefan gefragt, der testet für CT-E-Bikes.
Durch die alternativen Apps ist man schon in der Lage, dass man das Rad im Prinzip bis in alle Ewigkeit benutzen kann.
Aber es werden Funktionen wegfallen.
Zum Beispiel die GPS-Ortung, wo man in der App sehen kann, wo sich das Fahrrad gerade befindet.
Stimmt, ja, sowas muss ja über einen Hersteller-Server gehen.
Das wird irgendwann nicht mehr funktionieren.
Die Fahrräder haben ja im Moment auch noch einen Datentarif und kommunizieren mit den Servern.
Wenn die Server abgeschaltet werden, wird FANMOV irgendwann auch direkt...
Moment, die Fahrräder haben eine SIM-Karte drin?
Ja gut, muss ja. Muss ja.
Wie soll das sonst seine GPS-Daten senden können?
Muss es ja. Da ist eine SIM-Karte drin.
Brauch ja nicht viel Daten.
Und das ist günstig.
Sowas gibt es ja schon für 5 Euro oder 2,50 Euro im Monat oder sowas.
So Datentarife für ein paar 100 MB.
Das reicht ja. GPS-Daten sind ja nicht groß.
Und wenn du da alle, keine Ahnung, alle halbe Stunde mal an einen Standort schickst,
wenn es sich bewegt hat, nennenswert, dürfte das nicht viel Daten sein.
Für die eingebauten SIM-Karten, die Datenmodems, die in den Rädern drin sind, nicht mehr bezahlen.
Das Rad wird wahrscheinlich auch immer eine Fehlermeldung im Display anzeigen.
Und der Service von FANMOV, dass diese sogenannten Bike-Hunter, die ein geklautes Fahrrad orten und zurückbringen,
dem wird es dann aller Voraussicht auch nicht mehr geben.
Danke, Stefan.
Ja, und all das zeigt recht anschaulich, was der Always-Connected-Internet-of-Things-Smart-Trend für riesige Nachteile hat.
Okay, kaufe ich mir ein digitales Videospiel oder einen Film bei Anbietern wie Steam oder Amazon,
dann ist mein Kauf weg, wenn der Anbieter kein Geld mehr hat und die Server abschaltet.
Daran haben wir uns allerdings schon gewöhnt.
Und da gibt es ja zumindest Alternativen.
Die meisten Spiele kann man, wenn man das will, immer noch physisch auf Datenträgern kaufen.
Und Blu-Rays gibt es ja auch.
Also noch.
Dass man aber nun auch bei größeren Anschaffungen wie Fahrrädern, Autos, Staubsaugerrobotern oder was auch immer
inzwischen darauf achten muss, dass die Teile womöglich wertlos werden, wenn die Hersteller pleite gehen und die Server abschalten,
ist, glaube ich, noch nicht in allzu vielen Köpfen angekommen.
Aber stellt euch nur mal vor, ihr kauft...
Überlegt euch mal.
Das trifft ja teilweise auch auf neue Kühlschränke zu, wo die Leute der Meinung sind,
oh, wir kaufen einen Kühlschrank, der besonders smart ist.
Und dann denkt sich der Hersteller, ah, hat sich doch nicht so gut verkauft.
Wir geben jetzt mal hier einen Notice.
Und in einem Jahr schalten wir es ab.
Na geil.
Dann hast du dann zwar ein großes Display an deinem Kühlschrank vorne dran.
Aber je nachdem, wie viel Cloud-Funktionalität das benutzt, geht es dann halt einfach nicht mehr.
Das ist halt voll für den Arsch.
Ich meine, ich habe einen Katzenbrunnen.
Ja.
Acara Katzenbrunnen.
Weiß nicht, ob das Acara ist.
Ne.
Ja.
So, ihr Petfountain.
Und normalerweise braucht das Ding Internetverbindung.
Damit man das steuern kann.
Es geht zwar auch lokal, aber dann nicht sonderlich lange.
Das Ding, das braucht alle einmal in der Woche eine Verbindung zum China-Chinesen-Server.
Ansonsten stellt es die Funktionalität ein.
Knopf geht dann, glaube ich, noch.
Aber das Bedienen über WLAN geht nicht mehr.
Das ist dann schon extrem hängen geblieben.
Schauen wir mal, ob irgendwie einer da custom macht.
Ob einer da custom Firmware für sich schon gebaut hat.
Man weiß ja nie.
Ne.
Wahrscheinlich.
So weit sind wir schon, ja.
Tesla für eine, sagen wir mal, sechsstellige Summe.
Ja, was passiert, wenn der Hersteller pleite geht?
Und die Server abstellt?
Welche Funktionen gehen dann alle nicht mehr?
Ich finde, diese Fragen muss man sich vor den Kauf stellen.
Und die müssen die Hersteller einem eigentlich auch beantworten.
Ist klar, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass solche Riesenfirmen wie Amazon, Apple oder Microsoft,
bei Tesla bin ich mir nicht so sicher, den Betrieb einstellen.
Ne, die stellen nicht den Betrieb ein.
Aber die werden halt das machen, was beispielsweise mit alten Game-Servern passieren wird.
Die sagen vielleicht nach Zeit X, sagen die, ach, das lohnt sich nicht mehr, das weiter zu betreiben.
Ganz im Ernst, stellt euch mal vor, ihr seid ein Hersteller, der verkauft Kühlschränke.
So, und ihr habt jetzt einen super krassen, smarten Kühlschrank rausgebracht.
Und die Leute kaufen den.
Aber ihr stellt fest, nach irgendwie zwei, drei Jahren,
das Ding hat sich nur irgendwie 800 Mal verkauft.
Und wir betreiben dafür richtig viel Infrastruktur und Entwickler und alles.
Und irgendwie hat sich das nicht so wirklich gelohnt, diese Produktreihe.
Und ihr stellt die ein.
Und dann sagt ihr, okay, hm, wie lange sollen wir denn jetzt die Server weiter betreiben?
Oder wie lange sollen wir jetzt, wie lange sollen wir noch die Smartphone-Apps updaten?
Und dann sagt ihr dann als Hersteller, okay, wir schreiben jetzt, das Ding geht end of life.
Und die Server laufen noch ein Jahr oder zwei Jahre, dass du auch garantiemäßig alles abgedeckt hast,
was, falls sich jemand neu gekauft hat, sagt er, zwei Jahre noch.
So, und dann hast du nach, sagen wir mal, drei oder vier Jahren, wenn das Ding nicht erfolgreich gelaufen ist,
einen Kühlschrank, wo die Hälfte der Funktionen nicht mehr funktioniert.
Weil der Hersteller der Meinung ist, oh nö, wir schalten das jetzt ab.
Das ist durchaus realistisch.
Auf der anderen Seite, was soll der Hersteller machen, wenn das nicht erfolgreich war?
Sollen sie es 30 Jahre betreiben?
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen.
Neue Smartphone-Versionen unterstützen die App dann zunehmend schlechter und manche Sachen gehen dann nicht mehr.
Also selbst, wenn man es einfach nur so auf Legacy-Modus oder auf Maintenance-Modus online lässt
und nichts mehr updatet, was ist mit Sicherheitsproblemen?
Und vor allem, was ist mit neuen Smartphone-Versionen und der App, die dann vielleicht nicht mehr richtig funktioniert?
Also, das muss man sich ernsthaft überlegen, ob man Sachen für viel Geld kaufen möchte,
also wo man viel Geld für Zusatzfunktionen ausgeben möchte,
neben den normalen Basic-Funktionen wie kühlen, was so ein Kühlschrank hat,
und man dann ohne diese Funktionen da sitzen möchte, im Zweifelsfall 3, 4 Jahre später, sollte es Probleme geben.
Warum hast du Chromium und Chrome bei?
Das, ja, warum nicht?
Hier habe ich den Chat auf, hier habe ich YouTube auf.
Warum nicht?
Ich habe sogar noch Firefox. Zusätzlich.
Und für ganz harte Leute.
Ich hätte sogar noch Harddisk.
Und für ganz harte Leute. Ich hätte sogar noch Harddisk.
Zwei teaches haben wir gewesen.
Oops.
Kommánhæ?
Mein nein.
Da brauche ich mal wieGM.
Wir machen dieses Video mal.
Und mal Carbon Gratie.
でも、
Da kommen die doch einmal hin.
Shannon von Dose.
Vergiss es, das wird es halt so nicht geben.
Oder gibt es bei wenigen Sachen.
Da muss man sagen, da ist der Hersteller von meinem Ladegerät fürs Elektroauto.
Die sind da ganz gut.
Ich habe ein, wie heißt das Ding?
E-Go.
Hier.
So ein Teil habe ich.
Go E.
Charger.
Home.
Fix.
Und was haben die denn für Zubehör eigentlich?
Passendes Zubehör für dein E-Auto.
Okay, ein Kabel brauche ich jetzt nicht wirklich.
Oder was gibt es denn da Tolles?
Was haben die für Zubehör?
Okay, die sind alle furchtbar glücklich, weil sie jetzt diesen Charger haben.
Also es wäre nicht möglich, dass der Vater ein bisschen Gitarre spielt für das Kind ohne das Ladegerät.
Und dass der mit der Fernbedienung auf dem Sofa sitzt, wäre ohne das E-Auto-Ladegerät.
Auch nicht möglich.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Was haben die denn hier zu bieten?
Ja, das bringt mir nichts.
Es gibt, okay, es gibt Ladekabel.
Da habe ich schon welche.
Das brauche ich nicht nochmal.
Nützliche Helfer.
Kabelhalterung Typ 2.
Ich habe daneben, daneben ist so eine, so eine, daneben ist ein Wasserhahn.
Da lege ich das immer drauf.
Braucht man nicht.
RFID-Tags.
Teile deine Ladestation mit dem Nachbarn.
Ne.
Ja.
Zumindest, warum ich euch das eigentlich zeigen wollte, die muss man, die muss man tatsächlich mal loben.
Oh, was ist das für ein Ding?
Der Go-E-Controller.
Maximiere den einfach.
Also das ist für, verstehe.
Habe ich, habe ich ja noch keine.
Mal gucken, so wie sich das preislich aktuell darstellt und mit Handwerker und so werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht so schnell eine Solaranlage auf dem Dach haben.
Was ich bei denen richtig gut finde.
Die Firmware ist zwar meines Wissens nach nicht so gut.
Nicht Open Source, glaube ich zumindest.
Aber die haben, wie man hier sieht, die haben ihre API-Specs online.
Das ist schon mal ganz nice.
Du kannst beispielsweise Cloud-API dir angucken, wie das, wie das funktioniert.
Und auch wie die lokale API funktioniert.
Die haben nämlich die Möglichkeit, dass du lokal übers WLAN zugreifst und deine komplette.
Dein komplettes Ladegerät steuern kannst, ohne Cloud.
Du kannst das bei denen auch mit der Cloud verbinden, aber es geht alles auch ohne Cloud.
Und dadurch, dass die APIs öffentlich verfügbar sind und dokumentiert sind, wie die funktionieren, kann jeder Integration bauen für das Ladegerät.
Und das Coole ist, die unterstützen als API sowohl HTTP-API, TCP-API und MQTT-API.
Das heißt, es gibt selbstverständlich schon eine fertige Home Assistant.
Integration dafür, die über MQTT geht.
Und die benutze ich im Endeffekt auch.
Falls das die hier ist.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich die Integration benutze.
Aber ja, das funktioniert an den Kombinationen.
Also, das finde ich auch okay.
So, dass man es lokal steuern kann.
Dass man weiß, wie man es lokal steuern kann.
Und dass man im Zweifelsfall auch eine lokale API irgendwie nachbauen könnte.
Wenn man der Hersteller sagt, ich will das nicht.
Ich will das nicht.
Wenn man der Hersteller offline ist.
Was in dem Fall nicht notwendig ist.
Aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Also, das muss ich sagen, das hat der Hersteller gut gemacht.
Und es war auch eines der Gründe, warum ich mir dieses Teil gekauft habe.
Weil es lokale Steuerungsmöglichkeiten hat.
Und, ich finde, es sieht eigentlich auch ganz nice aus.
Die haben RGB-LEDs hier drumherum.
Das sieht man jetzt normalerweise gar nicht.
Die leuchten dann in unterschiedlichen Farben, je nachdem, wie weit das Chargen ist.
Wisst ihr übrigens?
Ratet mal, auf welchem Micro-Controller das Ding basiert.
Kommt euch das Ding irgendwie bekannt vor, da hinten in der Ecke?
Kommt euch das Teil irgendwie bekannt vor?
Das sieht halt einfach aus wie so ein 0815-Node-MCU-Modul.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es ein ESP-2866 oder ein ESP-32 ist.
Ich glaube sogar, dass es ein ESP-2866 noch ist.
Gucken wir mal, vielleicht sieht man es hier besser.
Also, vom Modul her würde ich eher sagen, ein ESP-2866.
Ein ESP-2866.
Auch mit den Pins hier.
So hundertprozentig sagen kann man es nicht.
Aber es ist, glaube ich, ein ESP-2866.
Ja.
So sieht es aus.
Und das war der Grund, warum ich mir das Teil gekauft habe.
Einfach, weil du es gut lokal steuern kannst.
Ist ziemlich gering.
Aber ganz ausschließend kann man das nicht.
Ich meine, VanMoof war noch vor wenigen Jahren der absolute Überflieger im E-Bike-Business.
Ja, warum sind die eigentlich pleite?
Ich dachte, das hat sich so gut verkauft.
200 Millionen US-Dollar Risikokapazität.
Das war ein Erfolgsunternehmen.
Ganz genau kann man auch nicht sagen, wie es zum finanziellen Niedergang bei VanMoof überhaupt kam.
Vermutlich waren das Qualitätsprobleme und überbordende Reparaturkosten.
Oder Management hat es verkackt.
Aber eigentlich ist das ja auch egal.
Wichtig ist nur, dass die Leute, die die Fahrräder gekauft haben, jetzt ein Problem haben.
Und das finde wahrscheinlich nicht nur ich hochproblematisch.
Oder wie seht ihr das?
Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare.
Und auf jeden Fall Augen auf beim Kauf von smarten Dingen.
Tschüss.
Das stimmt.
Oh, die YouTube-Polizei ist wieder am Start, Leute.
Der Titel ist nicht ganz korrekt ausgedrückt.
Solche Produkte werden nicht zu Elektroschrott.
Sie sind bereits beim Kauf Elektroschrott.
Hä? Okay.
Actually, genau.
Es kommt drauf an, was kaputt ist.
Also, ich denke mal, ein Großteil dieses Fahrrads wird ja ganz normales Fahrrad-Technik sein.
Also, wenn da jetzt mal irgendwie die Kette kippt.
Kaputt geht oder so.
Das wird hier schon jemand reparieren können.
Aber sollte halt beispielsweise das Schloss nicht mehr richtig funktionieren und sowas.
Da wirst du wahrscheinlich auf verlorenen Posten stehen, dass das repariert wird.
Das sind in dem Fall, ja, heiße User, aber das sind eher YouTube-Kommentierer, die so dummes Zeug schreiben.
Ich habe auch unter meinen, also unter meinen Videos gibt es erstaunlich wenig nervige Leute, aber ab und zu gibt es doch mal welche.
Der Akku ist fest verbaut.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich.
Also, kannst du das Ding, wenn es viel benutzt, wahrscheinlich eh in 5, 6 Jahren wegschmeißen.
Oder wahrscheinlich sogar nur in 3, 4, weil vielleicht haben es ja Leute schon 3, 4 Jahre.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch Schönes?
I seriously almost just got hacked.
Das ist doch Cheebait, das Video.
Das muss Cheebait sein.
Max, können wir über die Apple-Brille reden?
Da gibt es doch nicht allzu viel zu reden.
In ein paar Jahren können wir mal gucken.
Das ist jetzt ja...
Das ist ja quasi eher was für Entwickler.
Und in 2, 3 Jahren, wenn es da eine normale Consumer-Variante von gibt und vielleicht die Entwickler schon ein paar coole Anwendungsideen hatten und Apps gebaut haben und sowas.
Dann können wir mal darüber reden.
Aber aktuell gibt es da ja noch nicht so viel zu sagen zu.
Ich glaube, Fun-Move-Fahrräder kriegt man aktuell ziemlich billig.
Lass uns mal gucken.
Kann man sowas bei Amazon kaufen?
Nee.
Kann man nicht.
Was kostet denn sowas?
Shopping.
Ich würde sagen, geht ja.
Aber im Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass die Dinger halt aktuell kurz vor nicht mehr funktionieren sind, vielleicht doch keine so gute Idee.
Puh.
Ah, damit schon ordentlich.
Ah ja, okay, man kann nichts Neues mehr bestellen.
Ah, schon ordentlich.
Lecker.
Lecker Amsterdam.
Ja, aber das ist doch kein Vergleich.
Wenn du ein Fahrrad haben willst, willst du ein Fahrrad und keinen Gebrauchtwagen.
Weil du fährst.
Wenn du Fahrrad fahren willst und nicht Auto fahren willst.
Moin.
Doch, ich weiß nicht, was los ist, aber gestern war der Tag der Dorffeste.
Dort, wo ich laufen war, Dorffest.
Dort, wo ich zurück war, zurück vom Laufen kommen, Dorffest.
Dann bin ich bei mir hier rumgelaufen, an zwei Stellen, Fest.
War gestern irgendwas?
Habe ich irgendwas verpasst?
War 22.07. ist da irgendwas?
Ja, keine Ahnung, was da los ist.
Warum?
Ja, bei uns an der Kirche auch.
Fest, alles.
Weiß nicht, was 22.07. ist.
Mein Vatertag und so ist ja schon vorbei.
Okay, also, I seriously...
Das ist Cheatbait.
Das ist so krasser Cheatbait, das Video.
Okay.
Nein, okay.
Ich sage noch nichts, wir gucken mal weiter.
Der andere ist Mystery Walker, den meisten benutzen sie nicht.
Wisst ihr, was ganz einfach ist, wie man komplett diesen Problem aus dem Weg gehen kann?
Solche Sachen einfach unter Linux in einer VM machen.
Mache ich auch.
Also, wenn ich irgendwelche E-Mails kriege, mit Anhängen und sonst was.
Ich mache einfach mal ein Linux-VM auf, e mail, und gucke da rein.
Da hast du die Probleme alle nicht.
Das eigentliche Problem ist diesen ganzen Shit unter Windows machen zu wollen.
... benutzen und auch ich habe es bald nicht mehr.
Also, was ich mache, ist zu erklären, wie genau ich BamBam bekommen habe.
Ja, okay, leider.
Okay.
Schau mal gut.
Und Console-App 1, prinzipiell der beste Name dafür.
Das mach ich nie, das ist tatsächlich ein Problem.
Das mach ich aber nie, ich geh immer auf die, ich guck mir immer die GitHub-Seite davon
an.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Problem, das ist übrigens, ein ähnliches Problem gibt
es mit jedem Package-Manager, auch bei npm und Python und so, bei npm haben sie es mittlerweile
wenigstens so gemacht, dass keine Post-Install-Skripts und so mehr standardmäßig ausgeführt werden,
aber du kannst dir selbstverständlich mit einem Package-Manager einfach unendlich viel
Shit auf deinen Rechner holen, ja.
Okay, da weißt du schon, da ist der Gebet am Start.
Ja.
Hi Max, kann mir eventuell jemand helfen, wenn du sehen willst, was in Linux alles installiert
ist, RPM minus qa, ql, oder was ist denn für ne Distribution?
Was ist es für ne Distribution?
Alpine weiß ich nicht.
Mint, abt, abt list, abt list.
Abt list minus minus install.
Meines wegen, ja, okay.
Ja.
Oder dpkg
minus l
ist es, minus i ist install.
Ja, easy.
Easy.
Wir sollten Consulting-Gebühren nehmen.
Guck, ich kann dir sogar live zeigen.
Pass mal auf.
Docker run
Ubuntu.
Funktioniert das so?
Ne, äh, äh.
Docker run Ubuntu.
Ähm.
Wie ich mir das immer nicht merken kann.
Minus, minus, äh, m.
Ah ja, hier, guck, da, da.
Alles klar, so.
Da, guck.
Upt, list, minus, minus,
installed.
Zack, da siehst du, was du installiert hast.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
It's
easy.
Easy.
Okay, weiter gucken.
Rest.
I obviously thought that was weird, so then I looked at the info page on the Nuget site for the package and the account was called Nuget Solutions, alright?
Hehehe.
So.
Also, wie gesagt, ich würd mir immer mal den Source Code zu Gemüte führen davon.
And then I noticed that it had other packages also on.
Xbox.
Ahhhh, Discord.
Okay, das ist ein, das ist das erste Mal, dass ich so, so malicious package gedönst auf Nugets.
NPM ist ja Standard, dass da laufend irgendein Bullshit ist und gerade irgendwie die Hälfte der neu veröffentlichten NPM-Packages sind irgendwie Bullshit.
Oder Werbung, ist auch geiler Trend, dass Werbung auf NPM veröffentlicht wird.
Kein Witz jetzt.
Wird gespammt auf NPM.
All of them with hundreds of thousands of downloads.
But they all claim to be popular packages like Xbox and Discord.
Ja, verdächtig, verdächtig.
And they also had weird characters in them.
And that's when I was like, oh, these are fake.
Verdächtig.
Oh, and if you were wondering, basically all those downloads are fake.
If you actually go to the full statistics on the Nuget page, you can see they're all unknown download sources.
So I'm pretty sure not that many people are actually falling for this, fortunately.
At this point I knew the package was probably not just fake, but also malicious.
Though I hadn't actually used the package yet, so I wasn't sure if I had been infected with anything.
So immediately I googled malicious Nuget packages and found a few articles that told me, yeah,
they are a thing.
The article talked about how these malicious packages use a PowerShell script called init.ps1
and it takes advantage of some legacy feature where Visual Studio, if it sees that file name
for a PowerShell script in that directory called tools, it will just automatically execute it immediately.
Warum baut Microsoft immer so einen Shit ein?
Auf der einen Seite geben sie sich mega viel Mühe.
Um das sicherer zu machen.
Und dann haben sie noch so viel Shit drinne, wo alle anderen Sicherheitsmaßnahmen wieder untergräbt.
...upon downloading the package and anytime you open the project, too.
So I did a search on my computer and yes, sure enough, in the package directory there was a PowerShell script called init.ps1.
And when I looked inside it, yup, what it did was download and run a file called anthrax.bat.
Der Name klingt schon sehr faszinierend.
Sehr vertrauenserweckend, ja.
...which was the actual malware payload.
Now, me knowing that potentially the script could have been blocked by my app blocker policies,
I immediately rushed to the Windows Event Viewer.
Also das erste, was ich jetzt gemacht hätte, wäre mal mein Netzwerkkabel rausziehen.
Wenn ich den Rechner weiter benutzen möchte, um zu analysieren.
Ich würde jetzt an der Stelle spätestens, hätte ich mein Netzwerkkabel rausgezogen.
...and looked at the logs.
And I was relieved to see, that AppBlocker had indeed prevented the script from running.
And what's crazy and scary is, I might not have even realized what had happened,
if it hadn't been for that error message about the invalid character that caused me to look more into it.
So, for this specific scenario, if you do use NuGet with Visual Studio,
what you should do is, before you download any of the packages, even through Visual Studio...
Es ist ja noch besser, wir sind am Programmieren mit Rider unter Linux.
Da hat man zwar potenziell eventuell ähnliche Probleme, aber es ist zumindest ein isoliertes Environment.
Go to the actual NuGet Gallery and look at the page for that package and then look at the package explorer.
Also das stimmt, aber das Beste ist erstmal, sich überhaupt das Projekt anzugucken.
Also wenn das Projekt schon mal keine...
Ich meine, wir können uns das doch mal anschauen hier jetzt.
So, wir machen mal einen Snapshot, wer weiß, wer weiß, was Sache ist.
Wir können uns das doch mal kurz anschauen.
Ich hoffe...
Wahrscheinlich ist nach dem Video das Package sogar schon wieder weg.
Übrigens, nice am Frühstücken, der Pepo hier.
So, hier, Console App 2.
Beste.
NuGet Package.
Äh, NuGet Package...
Wo haben sie das denn hin?
Ist der da versteckt?
NuGet Package.
OpenAI hat er gesucht, gell?
Ich finde das Package gar nicht.
Von ihm.
Das hieß einfach nur OpenAI.
Wahrscheinlich ist es entfernt.
Kann das sein, dass es entfernt ist mittlerweile?
NuGet.
OpenAI.
Und dann sortieren wir mal nach Downloads.
Hier.
Das da, gell?
Das hier.
Von...
Org Go Do It.
Source Repository.
Ne.
Das war ein anderes, weil das ist ein...
Das ist ein offiz...
Das ist ein bekanntes Open Source Projekt Package.
Das ist was anderes.
Es ist weg.
Es ist weg anscheinend.
An...
Anscheinend ist es weg.
Die waren schnell aktiv und haben es gelöscht.
Or Feature.
Wir gucken nochmal kurz.
Wir sind bei 354.
Hier.
Bei NuGet Solutions.
NuGet Solutions.
Ich dachte, man kann nach dem User vielleicht suchen.
Must...
Okay.
NuGet.
Kann man suchen nach...
Ne.
Okay.
Die haben das...
Die haben den Typ wahrscheinlich gelöscht.
Vermutlich.
Ich trink keine Energy Drinks.
Keine Ahnung, wie das schmeckt.
Ich trink auch...
Ich trink auch so gut wie keinen Kaffee.
Ich trink eher Tee.
Ganzen Tag.
Ja.
Ntracks.biz.
ist, it lets you decide what executable files and scripts are allowed to run on your computer
through a whitelist or allow list model.
You see, normally when using...
Ja, whitelist ist böse, darf man nicht mal sagen.
Okay, das war es doch eigentlich schon, oder?
Das ist alles, um was es hier ging.
Finally, you're probably wondering more about this malware that I potentially got infected with.
Well, I went into a virtual machine and downloaded that anthrax.bat file,
though I wasn't going to run it myself, even inside a virtual machine.
Instead, I uploaded it to VirusTotal, which, if you didn't know, has a behavior tab,
which runs the file inside virtual machines designed to analyze malware and see exactly what they do,
which we'll take a look at in a second.
At the time I uploaded the file, it had never actually been seen before,
so there really weren't many signatures for it.
So in cases like that, you would have to rely on your antivirus's heuristics detection,
which basically looks at its behavior after,
it executes, and tries to determine whether what it's doing is malicious.
Though now many more do detect it via signatures automatically.
Was hat's gemacht?
Anyway, it turns out that this batch file was actually a renamed executable file,
and a pretty nasty malware at that.
One called Seroxin, which is a remote access trojan, or rat.
And more specifically, it's apparently a plugin for Seroxin called Nugeta,
that I guess targets Nuget repositories.
So yes, even malware these days has plugins.
I also happened to find a page advertising this Nugeta malware,
and it described itself as a stealer.
So presumably it would be going for things like cryptocurrency wallets,
and also session tokens from web browsers and stuff.
So yeah, my channel was pretty close to turning into an Elon Musk crypto scam stream.
Looking for the...
Ja, okay. Oh nee, nee, bloß keine 5-Kubernetes-Cluster daheim jetzt.
Ja, das kann ja relativ easy passieren.
Übrigens, das ist jetzt nix Visual Studio.net spezifisches, also in dem Fall schon.
Aber insgesamt, die ganzen Package-Manager haben so Probleme.
Also ich rede jetzt nicht von den offiziellen Package-Managern von einem Linux-System.
Die haben so Probleme eher nicht, weil das sind ja offizielle Paketquellen mit Hash,
alles gesichert mit Checksum.
Da gibt's keine Probleme.
Aber PIP oder NPM...
Oder Nougat oder sowas.
Da hast du potenziell schon Probleme.
Ich rebude mal.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Ackermans am Start.
Das kann uns übrigens nicht passieren.
Wir sind unter Linux in Rider unterwegs und installieren prinzipiell nur Nougat-Packages,
wo wir vorher das GitHub kontrolliert haben, was da eigentlich abgeht.
Ich mein, nicht alles im Detail, aber allein schon, wenn ein Public-Github-Repo existiert,
und da schafft es schon ein bisschen mehr Vertrauen.
Ob das jetzt exakt das ist, was als Nougat angeboten wird, das können wir natürlich
auch so nicht ohne weiteres verifizieren.
Ja, dann müsste man das Package selbst bauen.
Das macht ja kaum einer.
Welche Fonts muss ich inszenieren, damit die Icons gehen mit deiner Config?
Ähm, du brauchst...
Also einen Emoji-Font brauchst du erstmal nicht, auch wenn's praktisch ist.
Du brauchst...
Ich glaub, Powerline.
Ähm, warte mal hier.
Pacman-ql?
Wow.
Äh, ttf?
Warte mal.
Äh, Moment.
Pacman list installed packages...
Ach ne, das ist einfach nur q.
Äh, du brauchst wahrscheinlich...
Wahrscheinlich das hier.
Patched-Font...
Äh, patched-Hack-Font from Nerd-Fonts-Library.
Ja, das brauchst du.
Und ich habe zwei davon installiert.
Ich habe Meslo installiert und ich habe Hack installiert mit gepatchten Symbols.
Weil ich glaube, dass hier oben ist Meslo und nicht Hack.
Meslo ist, glaube ich, der Apple-Font.
Also das sind die Fonts, die ich installiert habe hier.
Ach ja, und Adobe Source Code habe ich auch noch installiert für China-Chinesen.
China-Chinesen-Buchstaben in GitHub.
Wie ist die Meinung zu Xamarin? Gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Es gibt jetzt MAUI und MAUI mag ich nicht.
Und Xamarin mochte ich auch schon nicht.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber du kannst dir zumindest, wenn du es mit dem offiziellen Package-Manager installierst,
relativ sicher sein, dass es sicher ist.
Es kommen aus offiziellen Quellen und es sind auch quasi beim Installieren
werden ja auch abgeglichen die Hash-Werte, ob das wirklich das offizielle Package ist.
Also mit dem normalen Package-Manager würde ich mir da keine Gedanken machen.
Ja, bei PIP und bei Nougat und bei NPM und so sieht es wieder anders aus.
Doch, kann man, kann man, aber ich mag beides nicht.
So.
Au, da.
Er will es ganz genau wissen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Du kannst natürlich in deinen Package-Manager auch nicht getrustete Package-Quellen hinzufügen.
Das stimmt.
Kannst du machen.
Dann bist du aber selbst ziemlich pipega.
Aber kannst du machen, natürlich.
Du kannst in deine Sources-List oder in deine YAM-Repo, wie heißt das Ding?
YAM?
Repos D, Repos YAML oder was auch immer.
Da kannst du auch irgendwelche untrusted Repos reinschreiben.
Aber standardmäßig, wenn du dein Betriebssystem installierst und ein standardmäßig mitgelieferter Package-Manager verwendest
mit den offiziellen Paketquellen, dann würde ich mir wenig Gedanken machen.
Was empfiehlst du für Android-App-Development?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich mache kein Android-App-Development.
Das Einzige, was wir mal gemacht haben, ist, wir haben versucht, aus der offiziellen Fiat-App
irgendwelche Sachen mitzusnippern.
Dafür habe ich den Emulator im Android-Studio benutzt.
Aber wir haben noch keine...
Also, die einzigen Sachen, die ich mal gemacht habe, die ein bisschen sich App-ähnlich verhalten,
das war Web-Service mit PWA.
Da konntest du dann die PWA auf deinem Smartphone installieren.
Das war zwar natürlich keine vollwertige App, weil Betriebssystem-Integration nicht so eng möglich war,
aber es war ja eh hauptsächlich ein Web-Service.
Und der hat unter Android am besten funktioniert, die App.
Weil Android Web-Notifications kann und iOS ja bis heute keinen Bock hat auf Web-Notifications.
Oder? Geht das mittlerweile?
Oh, wie das geht mittlerweile?
Ah, nee, Safari und iOS.
Requires Website to be first added to...
Ach ja, das geht mittlerweile tatsächlich.
Aha, das ist natürlich nicht schlecht.
Schon mal gut zu wissen, dass mittlerweile anscheinend Web-Notifik...
Da bin... Da wäre ich mir trotzdem nicht so sicher.
Ja, auch wenn das hier...
Hier steht, dass Web-Notifications gehen für PWAs auf dem Homescreen.
Okay.
Wäre sehr nice, wenn das funktioniert.
Klar, da gibt es jede Menge Worts von.
Musst du im Archiv gucken.
Gibt es jede Menge Worts von.
Guck.
Archiv.
Hab doch auf YouTube sogar letztens eine Playlist gesehen.
Ja, hier sind alle Worts vom Fiat Champ.
Gibt es eigentlich manchmal Comments auf dem Channel?
Beliebt.
Ja.
iOS flashen.
Quatsch mit Soße.
Pog-Subscription.
Dankeschön.
Huge.
Bei mir geht das mit Windows Key plus D nicht, dass ich Programme ausführe mit der E3-Config.
Muss ich da noch was Spezielles installieren?
Du meinst das hier?
Ja, musst du.
Du musst diesen Launcher installieren dafür.
Guck, wenn du in meine E3-Config guckst.
Also, redest du jetzt von meiner E3-Config?
Oder von deiner?
Von deiner Default-E3-Config.
Von der E...
Also, für die E3-Default-Config brauchst du dem Menu, glaube ich.
Und für meine...
Für meine brauchst du...
Siehst du ja auch hier.
Brauchst du...
Musst du Rofi installiert haben.
Siehst du ja auch hier.
Guck, was der ausführt.
Der führt das hier aus.
Unter der Haube.
Da musst du den hier installiert haben.
Und dafür habe ich auch gleich die Config hier mit dabei.
Ja.
Ich benutze das für Control-D.
Äh, nicht Control-D.
Windows-Taste-D zum Starten von Programm.
Und ich benutze das P für...
Mein Clipboard.
Clipboard-Manager.
Ja, und du kannst noch mehr Sachen machen.
Emojis einfügen und so.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
How JavaScript ruined the web.
Was haben wir hier?
Das schlimmste Spiel des Jahres und dessen Folge...
Oh Gott.
Oh nein.
Please.
Okay, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Geht auch nur acht Minuten.
Das war ja so ein Fail, Alter.
Ich habe mir das von Anfang an, ehrlich gesagt, bei diesem Game schon gedacht.
Weil, mal ehrlich, mal ehrlich, ja.
Hat sich irgendjemand...
Ich meine, erstens, Herr der Ringe ist eh schon seit ein paar Jahren nicht mal so super angesagt.
Aber hat sich irgendjemand, der Herr der Ringe geguckt hat, überlegt...
Oh.
Alter, ich wäre mal...
Ich bin immer gerne Gollum.
Niemand.
Keiner wollte je Gollum sein.
...bewiesen, dass wir es einfach drauf haben.
2023 ist eigentlich ein ziemlich nices Jahr für Gaming.
Es kam zum Beispiel das raus und das und das und das raus und das und das und das und fuck.
Unser allerliebtes Charakter aus der Herr der Ringe Welt, Gollum, hat sein eigenes Spiel bekommen.
Es hat komplett reingeschissen.
Von vielen wird es als das schlechteste Spiel des Jahres...
...bezeichnet.
Es war so ein Flop, dass das Entwicklerstudio kurze Zeit später schließen musste.
Wir tauchen ein wenig in die Gollum-Thematik ein, weil ich mir nichts Schöneres vorstellen kann als das.
Let's go.
Moin Max, ich bin heute in Frankfurt.
Was kannst du empfehlen?
Essen, Burger lehnen, Döner lehnen?
Ich war ganz lange in Frankfurt, nichts mehr großartig futtern, weil ich hauptsächlich Homeoffice mache.
Keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Klingt jetzt blöd, aber ich kann dir nichts Gescheites empfehlen.
Also was richtig gut...
...ist, wo du sagst, oh ja, da muss man mal unbedingt hin.
Also wenn du einfach nur auf die schnelle Mittag essen willst, kannst du zu Mexicana gehen, wo wir auch ab und zu mal hingehen.
Das ist aber eher so eine Subway-mäßige Kette.
Ja.
Das Teil in Frankfurt, ja.
Äh, nein.
Nein.
Ja.
So sieht das aus, ja.
Also, das ist auf der...
...der Kaiserstraße irgendwo.
Also wenn du am Bahnhof bist, kommst du da easy hin.
Ja.
Das ist jetzt nicht...
...würde ich nicht sagen, dass das super geil ist, aber wenn man mal schnell was Mittag futtern will, ist das ganz okay.
Also, vom Hauptbahnhof dahin dauert ungefähr 10 Minuten hin, 10 Minuten zurück.
Ich würde aber gucken, dass du vor 12 da...
...also, dass du nicht zwischen 12 und 13 Uhr dahin gehst.
Vor 12 ist...
...so, ey, vor 30 bis 12 ist okay und danach.
Ansonsten ist es zu voll.
Da war ich noch nicht.
Und ich war lange in Frankfurt auch nichts mehr großartig futtern, weil ich die letzten Jahre über fast nur Homeoffice gemacht habe.
Und auch vorhabe, das weiterhin so zu machen.
Ich kann dir wirklich nichts Gescheites mehr empfehlen.
Viele Läden, wo ich früher hingegangen bin, die gibt es gar nicht mehr.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Gollum ist dieses eine Spiel, nach dem niemand gefragt hat.
Herr der Ringe ist ein Universum...
Genau das denke ich mir auch.
Niemand wollte je Gollum spielen.
...so ein voller magischer Welten und Charaktere.
Wieso sollte man die nervigste und unnütze Kreatur von allen nehmen?
Das ist so, als würde man ein Videospiel...
Ich vermute mal, das haben die gemacht, weil die Marke billig oder das billig zu bekommen war.
Es hätte auch mit fast jedem anderen Hobbit irgendwie mehr Sinn gemacht.
...spongebob machen, aber man kann nur den alten Jenkins spielen und das Gameplay besteht nur darin, im Park spazieren zu gehen.
Wahrscheinlich wäre das sogar cooler gewesen.
Gollum ist ein chilliger Side-Character an einem großen Epos wie Herr der Ringe.
Ihn aber als Protagonisten.
Viele Stunden am Stück in einem Videospiel.
Ich wollte sterben.
Was für eine Flucht sei dieses Land.
Was für eine Flucht, was für eine Flucht.
Halt's Maul.
Er labert die ganze Zeit beim Spielen irgendeine Scheiße, was akkurat ist.
Das macht schließlich den Charakter von Gollum so ein bisschen aus.
Aber das fuckt ab.
Aber wer hat denn Bock darauf?
Wer hat Bock, das sag ich doch, wer hat Bock Gollum zu spielen?
Umgesetzt wäre das nochmal eine andere Story gewesen.
Aber das Spiel ist so schlecht, dass es weitaus größere Ausmaße annahm, als vermutlich jeder.
erwartet hat.
Verantwortliche für dieses Spiel sind der Dalek Entertainment.
Sitz in Hamburg, also wahrlich ein deutsches Videospielentwicklerstudio.
Kennen tun viele dieses Studio vermutlich durch Spiele wie Edna bricht aus oder Deponia.
Das sind Point-and-Click-Adventure-Spiele, die vor allem durch ihren Humor geglänzt haben und unfassbar gut angekommen sind.
Vor allem hier in Deutschland.
Solche Point-and-Click-Games sind so ein wenig ihr Steckenpferd geworden.
Es kam über die Jahre viele Spiele dieser Art raus, auch wenn sie zwischendrin trotzdem auch noch anderweitige Spiele entwickelt haben.
Mit der Zeit liefen diese Spiele aber immer schlechter.
Säulen der Erde floppte beispielsweise harten, aufgrund interner Probleme verließen immer mehr Talente das Team.
Der einzige Weg, um aus dieser Abwärtsspirale rauszukommen, so glaubte man scheinbar, war die Flucht nach vorne in eine große Triple-A-Produktion.
Herr der Ringe Gollum übersteigt alles, was das Studio in der Vergangenheit gemacht hat.
Sie sind hiervon hierhin gesprungen.
Das Ziel war es, das Unternehmen mit einem großen Kracher wieder Gesprächsthema werden zu lassen.
Und ich meine, also irgendwie haben sie es geschafft.
Es wurde eine ordentliche Stange Geld in die Hand genommen, um das am...
Die haben ja schon quasi eine Woche nach Release irgendeine Entschuldigung veröffentlicht da.
Die wurde wahrscheinlich im Vorfeld schon vorgeschrieben, für den Fall der Fälle.
...produkt erschaffen zu können, was von jedem angestrebt wurde.
Es stellt sich heraus, dass das Spiel Müll ist. Niemand hat es sich gekauft und das Studio musste schließen.
Das Spiel, das eigentlich deren Rettung werden sollte, wurde schließlich deren Untergang.
Gollum höchstpersönlich hat es geschafft, dass...
...dieses Team nie wieder entwickeln wird.
Aber ist das gerechtfertigt?
Das Game war gar nicht so teuer im Vergleich zu vielen anderen Triple-A-Games.
Aber es war halt trotzdem, also...
Vielleicht hat ihnen auch die Kohle gefehlt, ich weiß nicht.
Ich finde es vom Ansatz her schon dumm.
Ich hätte nie Bock darauf, Gollum zu spielen.
...fertigt.
Ich habe mir das Spiel tatsächlich gekauft und ich kann euch gerne von meinen Erfahrungen berichten.
Storytechnisch spielt das Spiel zwischen den Handlungen aus der Hobbit und Herr der Ringe...
...als Gollum eingesperrt war.
Man hat sich also den schrecklichsten Charakter genommen und gleichzeitig noch das schrecklichste Setting,
da man in dem Spiel die ganze Zeit im Knast ist und Sklavenarbeit verrichtet.
Man macht also das langweiligste, was man sich vorstellen kann.
Die Aufgaben, die man bekommt, beschränken sich im Endeffekt...
Gibt es, gibt es sowas wie Hate-Playing?
Wenn Hate-Watching und sowas gibt, gibt es sowas wie Hate-Playing?
Also vielleicht, vielleicht lohnt es sich unterm Strich finanziell sogar doch ein bisschen, weil so viele Leute es kaufen, um...
...um es zu haten.
...merkt immer auf, geh von A nach B und folge dieser Person, was auch Sinn ergibt.
Gollum kann nicht wirklich was anderes machen, weil Gollum komplett useless ist.
Er ist eine wahnsinnige schizophrene Kreatur, die nix kann und genauso wenig kann er auch im Spiel, außer rumhüpfen und rumklettern.
Es gibt...
Die, die Animationen sind halt auch so schlecht, guckt euch das mal an.
Und das war jetzt noch ne, das war noch eines der wohlwollenderen Sachen hier, guck mal.
...Kreatur, die nix kann und genauso wenig...
Guck mal.
Das ist immer...
Es werden überhaupt kein...
Nicht versucht, das zu interpolieren.
Du, du sn...
Du siehst einfach, wie, wie der komplett von der, von der normalen Bewegung zum nächsten Punkt snappt.
So.
Ich kann auch im Spiel auch...
Guckt euch auch mal an, wie er jetzt hier dran springt gleich.
Zack.
Und jetzt, und jetzt ist er instant attached da dran.
Es gibt kein richtiges Combat oder interessante Fähigkeiten, keine Ausrüstung, nix, was Gollum machen kann, außer rumzulaufen und irgendwelche Platforming-Passagen zu absolvieren.
Hier mal ne Wand hochlaufen, hier mal über paar Schluchten springen.
Das alles hätte vielleicht noch ganz...
Und vor allem die Gesichtsanimation, Alter, das ist das Schlimmste an dem Game.
Die resetten immer in so ne, so ne Art T-Pose-Gesichtsanimation nach jeder, nach, nach jeder Mimik, die abgespielt wird.
...wäre das Weltendesign nicht unfassbar shit.
In Spielen wie Assassin's Creed macht es Spaß, in der Welt herumzuklettern, da man immer einen passenden Weg...
Assassin's Creed hat aber für, für seine Zeit immer absolut top Animations gehabt.
Ich muss sagen, am meisten beeindruckt, es gab ein paar Spiele, die mich wirklich extrem beeindruckt haben zu, zu ihrer damaligen Zeit.
Die, was Animationen angeht, das eine war Uncharted, eindeutig.
Uncharted hatte, finde ich, für die Zeit da, und auch die späteren Teile, aber gerade beim ersten Teil, das war ja recht viel, mega, mega gute Animationen.
Vor allem halt auch, wie, wie Drake auf die Umgebung reagiert hat.
So, du läufst gegen ne Wand, du läufst nicht einfach gegen ne Wand, er, er macht den Fuß gegen die Wand und stützt sich dagegen, so mega, mega nice.
Und das andere, ein bisschen unterm Radar gelaufen, Max Payne 3.
Max Payne 3 hat er auch richtig gut gemacht, was das angeht.
Ja, und, ich meine, Assassin's Creed und so, die, die offensichtlichen, ja, aber...
Tja, und Gollum hat halt auch gezeigt, wie man das 2023 hinbekommt, dass es mieser aussieht, wie PS2-Spiele.
Weg suchen muss und alles schlau in die vorhandene Welt reindesignt wurde.
In Gollum ist es immer super offensichtlich, wo man hin muss mit weißen Kanten, an denen man sich festhalten kann, und sonst nirgendwo anders.
Man kann von den offensichtlich vom Spiel vorgegebenen Routen nicht abkommen, was es nach kurzer Zeit schon...
Alter, die sind, das sieht so falsch aus.
Ich meine, was hat der denn bitteschön für Kraft in den Ärmen, Alter?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Der springt mit den Ärmen dreimal höher als mit den Füßen.
...nach kurzer Zeit schon unfassbar langweilig werden lässt.
Oben drauf kommt noch Gollums schreckliches Gelaber die ganze Zeit.
Und die Steuerung.
Ich bin gestorben, als ich das Spiel gespielt habe.
Sehr schwammige Steuerung.
Was in einem Spiel, was halt darauf ausgelegt ist, die ganze Zeit herumzuschauen.
Umzuspringen, super nervig ist.
Ein anderes wichtiges Element in dem Spiel sind die Stealth-Abschnitte.
Wir müssen uns unseren Weg vorbahnen, ohne entdeckt zu werden.
Ist auch nicht wirklich schwer, weil die AI in dem Spiel dumm wie Scheiße ist.
Das sieht schlechter aus wie ein PS2-Game, Alter.
Die Orks, die einen nicht erwischen dürfen, haben einen exakt festgelegten Pfad, der vorhersehbarer nicht sein kann.
Man kann buchstäblich genau neben ihnen stehen und die sehen einen nicht.
Man muss wirklich exakt in die offensichtlichen Spots gehen.
Die gerade bewacht werden, um hier erwischt zu werden.
Das alles ähnelt irgendwie Zelda vom Nintendo 64, wo man nicht von den Wächtern erwischt werden durfte.
Mit dem Unterschied, dass dieses Spiel hier älter als meine Oma ist.
Es ist einfach weder gut, noch irgendwie spaßig umgesetzt.
Es ist keine Challenge, es ist in vielen Fällen sogar eher lächerlich.
Von den ganzen Bugs und Glitches, die in diesem Spiel existieren, wollen wir gar nicht erst anfangen.
Ich will ja fair sein.
Und es gab Sachen, die waren zumindest vom Gedankengang.
Ich finde es eigentlich echt cool.
Der gesamte Punkt von Gollum als Wesen ist, dass er ein verkommener Hobbit ist, der aufgeteilt zwischen zwei Persönlichkeiten ist.
Seinem eigentlichen Ich, Smergol und seiner wahnsinnigen Gollum-Seite.
Es gibt in dem Spiel Entscheidungen, die man tätigen muss.
Und hier gibt es immer eine gute und eine böse.
Je nachdem, für welche man sich entscheidet, muss man entweder seine gute Hälfte oder seine schlechte Hälfte...
Sag man sich... Ach, das sieht so unstimmig, einfach nur mies aus von der Optik her.
Wahrscheinlich hat es am Ende noch nicht mal irgendwelche Auswirkungen.
...Hälfte von der jeweiligen Entscheidung überzeugen, indem man mit sich selber diskutiert.
Von der Umsetzung her könnte...
Guck, hier sieht man es.
Hier sieht man, wie die Animationen immer resetten wieder.
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Na gut, das war jetzt ein bisschen überblendet.
Guck hier.
Hier ist die Animation.
Hier ist die Animation zu Ende.
Und jetzt kommen wieder so diese Standard-Quasi-Animations-T-Posts.
Von daher könnte es besser sein.
Man muss in dieser Diskussion oft raten und hoffen, dass man die richtige Dialog macht.
Aber ich finde die Mechanik an sich echt cool.
Außerdem cool ist der Fakt, dass die Dialoge der Elfen in Englisch aber auch in Sindarin auftreten.
Ja, Moment.
Sindarin gibt es aber nur als DLC.
Das ist ja das Geile da drin.
Das ist das Geile da drin.
Die wollen sogar, dass du extra für Voice Acting in...
halt, in elendschcem bezahlst.
...momit Ende genommen wurden.
Das ist die Sprache der Elfen innamoriert incarceration worden.
Sprache der Elfen in Herr der Ringe.
Das sind einfach nice Details.
Man kann im Menü einstellen, was man lieber möchte.
Wenn man das Geld dafür...
Genau.
...bezahlt.
Ich liebe es, wenn in Spielen zum Release direkt ein ganz großer Punkt im Menü herunterladbare Inhalte sind.
Die haben das Sindarin einfach hinter einer 3-Euro-Paywall gestellt.
Wow.
Ähnlicher merkwürdiger Natur sind alle Ingame-Käufe in dem Spiel.
Man kann sich zum Beispiel ein Emote-Pack kaufen.
Ich muss Geld bezahlen, damit Gollum in dem Spiel meinen Schatz sagen kann.
Für 5 Euro kann man sich das Lore Compendium kaufen, was eine große Ansammlung an Facts zur Herr-der-Ringe-Welt ist.
Ja, man kann auch einfach das Herr-der-Ringe-Wiki aufmachen.
Das ist super cool.
Wieso muss man dafür obendrauf zahlen?
Das Game hat 50 Euro gekostet.
Direkt einen Tag, nachdem das Spiel rausge...
Genau.
Jetzt kam erstmal die Entschuldigung.
Und ich wette mit euch, diese Entschuldigung wurde im Vorfeld formuliert, weil man schon geahnt hat, dass das Spiel kacke ankommt.
Komm, es hat Dedelec die obligatorische Entschuldigung gepostet.
Ein farbiger Screen, Logo, irgendein Rahmen, Text und zack, Gaming in 2023.
Es ist quasi schon ein Ritual für Game-Publisher geworden, diese Texte zu posten.
Und das Beste ist, dass es bei jedem immer derselbe Text ist.
Wir haben verkackt, es tut uns leid, tschüss.
Bei Dedelec muss irgendwas gewaltig bei den Führungskräften schiefgelaufen sein,
da man schon inmitten der Entwicklung hätte merken müssen, dass dieses Projekt zum Scheitern verurteilt ist.
Das war wahrscheinlich, wie sagt man so, too big to fail für die.
Haben ihr Entwicklerstudio komplett geschlossen und wollen fortan nur noch Spiele publishen, statt selbst zu entwickeln.
Das ist hart, da sie intern sogar schon an einem Nachfolger gearbeitet haben.
Haha, okay, die sind komplett lost.
Alter, haben die wirklich gedacht, na egal, Management vielleicht.
Die sind wahrscheinlich, also das ist ja eines der Hauptgründe für Unternehmen geht den Bach runter,
wenn Management-Leute komplett von der Realität entkoppelt sind.
Was hier anscheinend der Fall gewesen ist.
Sie dachten, dass es so gut ankommt, dass sie einen Nachfolger dazu rausbringen können.
Das ist fast schon traurig.
Gollum ist das Ergebnis davon, ein Projekt eventuell nicht ganz bis zum Ende durchdacht zu haben,
da das alles von der Idee bis hin zur Möglichkeit es umzusetzen von vornherein zum Scheitern verurteilt war.
Wir können uns wohl darauf einigen, dass wir nie wieder über dieses Spiel reden
und alle einfach so tun, als wäre all das nie passiert.
Ja, oh man, Alter, dieses Verkackt haben.
Das erinnert mich, die Story erinnert mich ein bisschen an, wie hieß dieser andere Adventure-Hersteller,
der dann auch immer teurere Lizenzen gekauft hat und die Spiele immer schlechter angekommen sind
und jetzt, jetzt glaube ich gar nichts mehr.
Wie heißen die, die Minecraft Story Mode gemacht haben?
Ich komme nicht drauf.
Ich meine, wir können googeln, aber vielleicht fällt es mir noch ein.
Telltale, genau, ja.
Bei denen war es ja auch so, da ging es den Bach runter.
Leider.
Leider werden wir Gollum 2 nie sehen.
Playing Minecraft on Windows 98.
Das ist halt der typische Ding, wo man sich fragt, warum?
Aber wahrscheinlich ist die Antwort, weil es geht.
Have it download everything via an IP address to your own server.
Because it looks like the color.
It looks identical to Minecraft Classic.
And not only that, look at how freaking smoothly it's running here.
We're getting consistently over 100 FPS, 150 FPS.
It affects 5200, which has a C-Level here.
100, we'll just default to 100.
Alright, so from left to right, PS.
Ja, warum auch nicht?
Ups.
Let's talk about the modern.
Okay, was haben wir hier noch zu bieten?
Leute, ich kriege langsam schon Hunger.
How JavaScript, oder JavaScript, wie es die coolen Leute sagen, ruined the web.
Ich würde sogar so weit gehen und sagen, JavaScript hat das Web überhaupt nicht ruiniert,
sondern mit zu dem gemacht, was es jetzt ist.
Ich meine, guckt mal, wie komplex und vielfältig von Funktionen Web-Anwendungen heutzutage sind.
Und es hat seinen Grund, dass Leute quasi 80% nur noch ihren Browser benutzen.
In der TTT.
In der täglichen Arbeit am Rechner oder am Smartphone oder so.
80% ist, würde ich mal sagen, ist Browser.
Und das ist Web-Anwendungen und auch JavaScript zu verdanken.
Also ich würde gar nicht sagen, dass es das Web ruiniert hat.
Das ist heute einfach anders als früher, aber von der Funktionalität her viel besser.
Macht sich natürlich im Titel besser, ja.
Das Modern Web, okay, das Modern Web ist nicht schlecht.
Ich muss sagen, auf dem Desktop sind viele Design-Entscheidungen mega kacke.
Zum Beispiel, dass viele Webseiten immer Tablet-artiger werden, sich Tablet-artiger bedienen lassen.
Zum Beispiel, bestes Beispiel für sind die YouTube-Kommentare.
Warum muss ich Endless-Scroll haben?
Endless-Scroll für YouTube-Comments ist der größte Bullshit ever,
was die eingeführt haben, Usability-mäßig auf der Seite.
Das ist auf dem Smartphone vielleicht ganz cool, da kannst du eine halbe Stunde runterscrollen.
Aber such mal einen Kommentar.
Also du kannst ja weder Kommentare suchen, ich weiß, es gibt Browser-Add-ons,
aber jetzt mal ganz im Ernst, auf dem Desktop, ja, warum kann ich nicht einfach,
und das funktioniert übrigens noch nicht mal richtig, wenn man die Stelle überscrollt,
wo es Kommentare nachlädt, guck jetzt erst, wenn man da ist,
warum könnte man nicht einfach sagen, okay, auf dem Desktop machen wir hier unten halt Pages,
dann gehe ich auf Page 5 und finde das Comment wieder, oder?
Ich kann wenigstens, wenigstens die Kommentare durchsuchen, aber nein, die Basics der Basics geht es nicht,
weil es eben nicht so einfach ist.
Es ist irgendwie so eine Billig-Mobile-Anwendung geworden ist.
Nun gut, ja, da kann man sich drüber aufregen, aber über Modern Web an sich eigentlich weniger.
Na gut, mal gucken, was er sagt.
Ja, New Reddit habe ich noch nie verstanden, was, warum das so geil sein soll.
Ich meine, New Reddit sieht ein bisschen besser aus als Old Reddit,
aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen, und das, das, das könnt ihr mir jetzt ja mal erklären,
vielleicht seid ihr Pfeifert genug, genug Prime-Subscribed heute schon,
IQ ist, explodiert hier im Chat, also, also vielleicht könnt ihr mir das erklären,
wer ist bei Reddit auf die Idee gekommen, dass es eine gute Idee ist,
die Inhalte, auf die es ankommt bei Reddit, nur noch zu 50% auf der Seite anzuzahlen, guckt euch, altes Reddit,
fast alles Inhalte, neues Reddit, Hälfte der Seite nur noch Inhalte, und das Wichtigste,
Kommentare in Reddit kannst du ja teilweise nicht mal richtig sehen, weil du 50 mal ausklappen musst.
Ich verstehe es einfach nicht, wie die das seit Jahren so verkacken.
Das ist ja auch nicht wirklich merklich besser geworden.
Das, das, das verstehe ich nicht.
Ich verstehe, warum sie die Webseite modern gebaut haben, ja, das verstehe ich,
aber warum man das Design macht, dass die Inhalte nur 50% einnehmen, das verstehe ich nicht.
Und, ähm, nicht, dass sie wie ein Google-Webpage...
Na ja, ohne Adblocker gehts ja prinzipiell schon mal nicht.
...in this Video I want to go over how this happened.
So, the simple answer for a lot of this is the Web's current obsession with JavaScript.
Now, of course, there's nothing wrong with JavaScript, people like to dog on JavaScript
Ja, das ist eher der geilste, geilste Bild davon.
...Java Script a lot, but inherently there's nothing really wrong with it.
mit it if you want to have any sort of interactivity on your website you're going to use it but the
problem really arrived with the popularity of javascript frameworks so maybe you've heard of
react angular view and many many more frameworks like this these are basically tools that web
developers use that abstract a lot of things in development away to make it easier to create
richer more dynamic web applications so basically what i'm saying is ich würde es gar nicht als
problem sehen ich meine im ernst im ernst so moderne webseiten die würde ja die würdest ja
mit nicht mit jquery bauen oder oder meint irgendjemand oder irgendjemand würde gerne
mit jquery bauen ja ich glaube doch eher nicht also die webseiten sind umfangreicher geworden
haben mehr funktionalität was auch dank der frameworks ist weil die funktionalität
besitzt
beziehungsweise die komplexität damit besser handeln kannst ja jquery ist immer noch auf so
vielen seiten ich glaube die top top 50 prozent der welt haben noch jquery ja also für mich ist
es hauptsächlich das webdesign was mich aktuell nervt wenn quasi webseiten sich reinführt auf
dem desktop rein für tablets und smartphones anfühlen javascript frameworks allow for highly
interactive web apps with a lot of moving
parts and that's basically what they are used for because the most popular react it was originally
developed by facebook and that's because it's very hard to have a website with the level of
complexity that facebook has without using a complex javascript framework yeah and so
these javascript frameworks they work best as single page er hat sich ein bisschen genervt
an irgendwie oder applications so these
are basically websites that you would expect to behave like applications
Also für so etwas wie ein Admin-Dashboard macht es Sinn, einen dieser Frameworks zu verwenden,
weil du ständig daraus und dazu und dazu daraus Dinge kreieren und editieren wirst
und du willst nicht, dass die Seite jedes Mal, wenn du eine Aktion nimmst, aufgeführt wird.
Das würde wirklich furchtbar und schnell werden.
Und diese Frameworks funktionieren am besten für Websites, die einen mittleren Interaktivitätstermin haben.
Das ist der Süßspot für diese JavaScript-Frameworks.
Aber das Problem besteht darin, wie breit die Adoption dieser JavaScript-Frameworks war.
Nun, sieh mal, einige dieser Websites machen Sinn, indem sie etwas wie React...
...react, aber sobald sie React benutzen...
Sobald sie React benutzen? Ah ja, benutzen anscheinend auch React. Okay.
...sobald sie React benutzen, benutzen sie React.
Und keine dieser Websites brauchen wirklich React zu benutzen.
Die Vorderseite dieser Websites müssen nicht wirklich so komplex sein.
Aber der Grund, warum React und diese anderen JavaScript-Frameworks die Internet-Storm verursacht haben,
ist, weil sie so verursacht haben, dass sie so komplex sind, dass sie so komplex sind, dass sie so komplex sind.
ist, weil sie so komplex sind, dass sie so komplex sind, dass sie so komplex sind, dass sie so komplex sind,
weil sie so komplex sind, dass sie so komplex sind, dass sie so komplex sind, dass sie so komplex sind.
Naja, also Marketing allein ist es sicherlich nicht.
Entwickler entwickeln halt einfach gerne mit einem ordentlichen JavaScript-Framework anstatt mit jQuery.
Und das muss auch nicht pauschal schlecht sein.
Dass viele Websites komplett sinnlos bloated sind und sich darauf verlassen,
dass jeder heute mindestens vier Kerne hat und 2Gb RAM frei für die Anwendung ist was anderes.
Aber so ein JavaScript-Framework, würde ich sogar mal so weit gehen und sagen,
ist meistens nicht das Problem dafür, wenn die Webseite scheiße ist.
Ja gut, PHP ist ja auch keine Alternative zu JavaScript.
Das glaube ich nicht, das glaube ich nicht, dass das Peer-Pressure ist.
Das ist, weil du mit einem ordentlichen Frontend-Framework
einfach viel angenehmer Web-Anwendungen bauen kannst,
als mit reinem Vanilla-JavaScript oder jQuery.
Ja, das ist die GitHub-Umfrage, äh, die Stack-Overflow-Umfrage,
die ist ein bisschen blöd gestellt.
Da geht es allgemein nicht um Frontend-Frameworks,
sondern um Frontend-Technologien und da kannst du auch für NPM abstimmen und sowas.
Du kannst React lernen, eines dieser JavaScript-Frameworks,
bevor du überhaupt JavaScript selbst lernst.
Und ich bin seit langer Zeit Web-Developer und seit langer Zeit
habe ich nur glücklich HTML- und CSS-Websites gemacht, als ich ein Kind war
und dann habe ich später auf WordPress-Websites gewechselt, wenn ein Klient es benötigt hat.
Aber ich habe auf ziemlich basischen Websites gearbeitet.
Aber wenn du anfängst, Web-Developer-Influencers zu folgen,
ich spreche über die Leute auf Twitter, die immer darüber sprechen,
über die neueste, neueste, größte Technologie,
das Weltbeste,
die jeder jetzt benutzen muss.
Also, du hörst diese Leute auf Twitter oder auf einem Podcast
oder sie sehen einen Blog-Post von ihnen.
Sie sprechen immer darüber, wie man Dinge in einer neuen und verbesserten Weise machen muss.
Oder du wirst im Grunde genommen hinterlassen,
weil das als das Zukunfts-Web-Development dargestellt wurde.
Da ist ja auch was dran.
Wenn du dich nie mit neuen Technologien beschäftigst, dann wirst du auch irgendwann hinterlassen.
Wichtig ist ja, also, es ist ja nicht unbedingt sinnvoll,
immer auf das Neueste für die nächste App aufzuspringen und das immer im Neuesten zu machen,
aber sich ein bisschen damit auszukennen und zu wissen, wann man was am besten benutzt
und die beste Technologie für den Anwendungsfall ist, das ist ja nicht verkehrt.
Wenn man einfach nur stur HTML, CSS macht und Vanilla-JavaScript,
damit kriegst du ja auch vieles gar nicht gescheit auf die Reihe,
ohne dass du das Rad neu erfinden musst.
Also, weiß nicht, irgendwie...
...irgendwie stimme ich dem Ganzen nicht so richtig zu bis jetzt.
Ja, gut, das...
Oh, nice, Leute!
Das ist doch Word-Art, oder?
Ja, gut.
Das musst du nicht wirklich mit React machen, da gebe ich ihm schon recht.
Ich glaube, Chico braucht auch unbedingt ihre eigene Webseite.
...improved way, the JavaScript framework way, that they can with this thing called Gatsby.
So, Gatsby was a really cool static site generator, but powered by React.
And so you could have a blog or just a simple informational website, but once your website loaded,
it hydrated into a fully featured React app.
And you get these cool seamless transitions, like you click onto a new page,
and it doesn't reload the page, it just kind of instantly takes you there.
And I remember thinking that this was the coolest thing ever, it was really slick,
and so of course I built my personal website with this framework, why wouldn't I?
But then after I finished with it, it felt a little bit weird,
because my website was loading slower than before.
So at the time, the slogan for this framework...
Gut.
...was also a little bit the problem, what single-page applications have.
They need a little bit at the first time, and they can't properly indicate the search engines.
So in this respect, yes.
That's why the latest trend is the opposite of that.
Well, not the opposite, let's say a hybrid of that.
Server-Site-Rendering with Client-Site Hydration.
So you initially render the page on the server, pack in the JavaScript state,
Frontend picks the state up and goes on.
Then you can use interactive things, dynamic websites and search engine indications
and fast loading times together.
That's the current trend.
The slogan was...
JavaScript is single-thread, you have something like WebWorker,
where it's a little bit different, but the principle is the same.
So the Frontend story, the interaction, it's all single-threaded,
but with IO callbacks, so to speak, or generally with callbacks.
So if you have to wait for something,
you can do it with, for example, async await,
then it jumps back to the point at the next loop when it should be finished.
Yes, but it's single-threaded.
In every way that matters.
And it definitely felt very slick, but very slow.
Because when you first try this, it does feel a little bit faster,
because, like I said, it doesn't have to reload the page in order to get new data.
But the initial page load,
of loading my website in for the first time,
was noticeably much slower.
That's because it had to load in all of this JavaScript
and parse all of it before you can write any HTML.
That's why people use Svelte.
Parsing hundreds of kilobytes of JavaScript takes much longer than parsing...
It's not for nothing that the most loved JavaScript framework is Stackoverflow.
...maybe 100 kilobytes of CSS or HTML.
And so after I built this, this was my first inclination
into realizing that something might be wrong with modern web development.
Why am I building this simple website, which should just be HTML and CSS?
Why does this need React?
Of course, this is a very extreme example,
building a completely static website with React,
but it just left me with kind of a bad taste in my mouth.
Like, really? This is supposed to be the future of web development?
Google möchte DRM in Chrome einbauen?
Ist doch schon lange.
Oder mal wieder, mal wieder Manifest 3 jetzt.
...the process of building this website,
cause it so many headaches.
So I was building my website with React.
Deswegen ist wichtig, dass es Firefox immer weitergibt.
Let's be version 1.
Ja, gut. Hey, Leute.
Eine NPM-Install ist generell immer eine schlechte Idee.
Egal welches Projekt du hast,
die Abhängigkeiten laden Abhängigkeiten laden Abhängigkeiten laden Abhängigkeiten.
Du kriegst 30 Milliarden deprecated warnings.
Das ist normal.
Also eine Node-Folder unter 8 GB
ist kein ernstzunehmendes JavaScript-Projekt.
Das lädt immer das halbe Internet runter.
Das ist ja Standard schon.
In Tech these days people like to move fast and break things.
And so while I was working on this project,
they upgraded to version 2 of Gatsby.
And switching to it was a major headache,
because there were so many incompatibilities
between the two versions.
I essentially had to completely rewrite my website.
And this is just kind of the feel of working with these modern web frameworks.
Everything's always changing
and you constantly need to be on top of things.
And if you're migrating to a new version,
things are just going to break.
You're just going to have to rewrite things and fix things.
Because there are so many moving parts in your website
that you need to pull in all of these dependencies
from all different kinds of people.
So even just a basic hello world example these days,
at least for Gatsby,
this framework I was working in at the time,
it brings in like a thousand packages.
And all of these packages add up to hundreds of megabytes,
just to create this very basic hello world example.
It's really ridiculous.
523 MB Node Modules,
that's still lightweight.
Ridiculous.
And you can imagine what happens
when websites are so complex.
They really become fragile.
That doesn't mean that your output website is 500 MB.
Your Node Modules folder is 500 MB.
One has nothing to do with the other.
Some of these projects,
if you come back a year or two later,
and you try to download them again
and edit something with it,
it literally doesn't work because
everything has changed,
like the Node.js version has changed.
And so it's no longer compatible
with all of these old libraries.
And if you upgrade some of these libraries,
then they're incompatible with other libraries.
It's really a major headache working with all of these frameworks
because there are so many moving parts.
But with everything I've told you,
you might now be wondering,
why would you want to use one of these complex frameworks?
Naja.
Das ist doch ganz klar.
Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass die Leute sagen,
oh, ich muss das jetzt benutzen, weil es hip ist,
vielleicht auch ein bisschen,
sondern weil vieles damit schlicht und ergreifend
deutlich einfacher ist als mit Vanilla JavaScript.
Mach mal mit Vanilla JavaScript so eine Sache wie,
du hast eine Input Box
und du willst einfach nur eine Überschrift damit aktualisieren.
Ja, ist nicht sonderlich kompliziert,
aber es ist schon nicht so einfach.
Du musst dich subscriben zum Input Event,
du musst die Tastendinger rausfiltern,
du musst neues HTML generieren,
appenden an irgendwas.
Das ist deutlich komplizierter als einen Input zu machen,
eine Textbox zu machen und per Data Binding
das da mit einem Callback dranzuhängen
mit irgendeinem x-beliebigen Frontend Framework.
Von da wird es immer nur noch komplexer.
Get Element by ID und so.
Ja, ist so.
Also damit ist einfach angenehmer zu arbeiten.
Es ist wirklich die einzige Technologie für Entwickler,
die man benutzen kann.
Das ist wirklich das, was die Entwicklungserfahrung
bis dahin bringt.
Weil wenn du eines dieser Frameworks nutzt,
macht es viele schöne Dinge für dich.
Ja.
Wie ich gesagt habe,
macht es Dinge wie Minify dein JavaScript,
Minify dein CSS.
In diesen Tagen mit jedem Framework
kannst du Hot Reloading haben,
also machst du eine Veränderung an der Website
in der Entwicklung
und es gibt sofort Updates,
während du daran arbeitest.
Und wenn du so wie ich bist
das erste Mal ein JavaScript-Framework nutzt,
scheint es fast magisch zu sein.
Das stimmt, da gebe ich ihm recht, ja.
Du kannst einfach Snippets und Libraries
von Millionen von NPM-Packagen importieren
mit einem einfachen Terminal-Kommand.
Und die Idee ist,
dass wenn du Dinge für Entwickler einfacher machst,
dann wird es ein bisschen
in eine bessere User-Erfahrung zurückfliegen.
Wenn wir neue Features schneller entwickeln können,
natürlich wird das alles für die User besser machen,
nicht wahr?
Nicht nur das,
aber arbeiten in jahrzehntelanger Technologie ist müde
und das neueste Framework,
das auf Twitter trendig ist,
ist viel mehr empfehlenswert,
als das, was du immer hast.
Es kann auch lustig sein,
dich selbst zu vorstellen,
was sehr viele Sachen einfacher macht,
als das, was du immer hast.
Wenn du die cutting-edge-Technologie nutzt,
die ein Start-up benutzen würde,
wie zum Beispiel die New York Times,
ein altes, dünnes Zeitungsbuch,
aber du wünschst,
dass du auf Twitter arbeitest,
also nutzt du all die coolen,
neuen Technologien,
die sie benutzen.
Und wenn all diese Werkzeuge
die Entwickler effizienter machen,
was ist damit falsch?
Natürlich kommt all das an Kosten,
und wahrscheinlich der größte Preis
ist die Leistung.
Und ich bin sicher,
dass du gehört hast,
dass wenn dein Website langsam ist,
dann wirst du wahrscheinlich
das Geschäft verlieren.
Weil wenn du ein Kunden bist,
der zum ersten Mal auf dein Website geht,
und es sehr langsam ist,
und sehr langweilig ist,
werden die Leute natürlich nicht
sehr lange auf deinem Website bleiben.
Aber diese Art von Leistung...
Naja gut,
das Bilderladen,
das liegt jetzt so beim besten Willen
nicht an React,
dass das so lahm ist.
... Aggressionen sind nicht
wirklich bis später,
bis es aktiv das Geschäft schmerzt.
Weil,
wenn du zuerst diese Framework benutzt,
Ja, Webpack ist auch abfuck.
... sie fühlen sich ziemlich schnell,
bis du all die Abhängigkeiten
und all die Ads und Tracks
ausladen musst.
Probier mal das Weltkit aus,
das finde ich am angenehmsten.
... dass auch auf deinem Website
benötigt werden.
Und nachdem du alles hinzufügst,
schlägt das Website wirklich
zu einem Crawl.
Aber lass uns auch darüber sprechen,
wer das beeinflusst.
Weil,
wenn die Bilder lahmladen,
das liegt nicht an dem
JavaScript-Framework.
Also, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Ich muss dir was erzählen.
Also,
ich habe schon Frontends gebaut,
mit,
ich glaube damals war es noch
Vue.js.
Nee, Svelte,
sogar mit Svelte.
Für ESP32-Microcontroller.
Also, die mussten klein sein,
die mussten da drauf passen.
Und Backend-mäßig
ging da auch nicht so viel.
Klar, natürlich kann ich auch
ein komplexes Frontend ausliefern
von einem ESP32,
was einen Achtkerner
in die Knie zwingt, irgendwie.
Aber das Framework ist meistens
nicht so sehr das Problem,
eher das, was damit gemacht wird.
Und dadurch, dass du mit
Vanilla JavaScript und ein bisschen
jQuery sehr viel
from scratch neu erfinden musst,
wenn du was Interaktives machen willst,
glaube ich nicht, dass es wirklich
so viel besser werden würde,
nur weil du es von Hand baust,
wenn du eben eine gewisse
Funktionalität im Kopf hast,
wie du das haben willst.
SvelteKit zu deployen ist
eigentlich relativ easy.
Du kannst entweder das Ganze
statisch generieren lassen,
wenn du seitens deiner
Webseite schon vorgerendert
ausliefern willst,
oder du schaltest diese ganze
serverseitige Geschichte einfach ab.
Also wenn du nicht
serverseitig rendern möchtest,
kannst du es einfach abschalten.
Dann wird das ganz normal
vom Webserver ausgeliefert
und läuft kleinseitig.
Blazing fast Internet connections
in developed countries.
But of course this affects people
using rural connections
and those in developing countries.
They don't always have
the fastest Internet.
Also okay, da hat er recht.
Wir haben in Deutschland
aber auch nicht
das fastest Internet.
Und ich bin mir nicht
so wirklich sicher,
ob die meisten Leute
als Zielgruppe User aus Afrika
bei ihrem Inlineskate-Webshop
in Deutschland haben,
zum Beispiel.
Also na ja, na ja.
Okay, es ist schon
ein bisschen was dran.
Und ich sehe das ja auch ein,
dass manche Webseiten unnötig bleiben,
unnötig bloated sind.
Ja, macht Facebook auf,
lädt erst mal 18 MB JavaScript runter
und sagt, das muss das alles sein?
Aber das kannst du schlecht
den JavaScript-Frameworks
in die Schuhe schieben.
Die JavaScript-Frameworks sind entstanden,
weil es Probleme zu lösen gilt
und nicht umgedreht.
Also es ist nicht so,
dass zuerst das JavaScript-Framework da war
und deswegen ist alles schlecht geworden,
sondern es gab Probleme,
die sich mit der bestehenden Technologie
nicht gut haben unter einen Hut bringen lassen.
Und daraufhin wurden dann so Sachen wie
React, Vue, Angular
und jetzt später noch Svelte erst entwickelt,
um manche Sachen besser handeln zu können.
Also das ist so ein bisschen falsch rumgedreht.
Not to mention that,
but a lot of people are using older devices
with 4 GB of RAM or less.
And this noticeably affects how long the page loads,
because again it has to parse all of the JavaScript.
That takes computing power.
And this becomes even worse on phones,
because let's face it,
a lot of people,
most people these days,
use the Internet on their phone.
And these websites just drain your battery
like no tomorrow.
Have you ever navigated to one of these websites
on your phone
and just literally watched as your battery dropped?
Nö.
Aber ich will nicht ausschließen,
dass es ein Ding ist,
wobei ich ganz stark davon ausgehe,
dass iOS und Safari
und bestimmt auch Android
solche Webseiten erkennt
und...
standardmäßig drosselt,
was irgendwelche Tickrates von JavaScript
und sowas angeht.
Und spätestens wenn du den Tab zumachst,
also...
Ja, aber okay, gette ich.
Aber da kann das JavaScript auch nichts dafür,
wenn die Webseite einen kompletten CPU-Core vollmacht.
Das liegt nicht an dem JavaScript-Framework.
Guys,
and these sites just provide a worse user experience.
So, have you ever clicked the back button
just to find out that it doesn't work
like you would expect it to?
That's because the back button has been hijacked
by the JavaScript-Framework
that that website is using.
And if they didn't implement it correctly,
well, oops.
And have you ever gotten caught
in an infinite loading circle?
Well, that's just because
all of the JavaScript didn't load in.
Because a lot of these frameworks,
they initially load in no HTML at all.
Ja, und deswegen ist der neueste Trend ja auch
Server-Site-Rendering, Hydration
plus JavaScript-Frontend.
Dass du so old school und...
und new school miteinander sinnvoll verbinden kannst.
Und ich glaube auch,
dass das quasi so für jahrelang jetzt so der...
immer weiter der Stand der Technik werden wird.
Es wird weggehen von reinem Server-Site-Rendering
bei denen, die es noch machen.
Es wird weggehen von reinen PWA's
für die, die es noch machen,
zu so einer Full-Stack-Geschichte
aus Server-Site-Rendering plus JavaScript-Frontend.
Das ist auch eine sinnvolle,
das ist eigentlich die logische Schlussfolgerung
aus der ganzen Sache.
Du renderst die Webseite Server-Site-Rendering
vorderseitig vor.
Du hast schnelle Load-Time.
Du kannst sogar so Sachen machen,
wie Edge-Computing,
dass du es möglichst nah auslieferst
am Anfrageort,
dass die Webseite besonders schnell lädt.
Und du kannst interaktive Sachen machen.
Du kannst die Webseite durchsuchbar machen
von Crawlern, von Suchmaschinen.
Also SSR mit Hydration und Frontend-JavaScript,
das wird sich durchsetzen.
Das hat sich schon durchgesetzt
und wird auch immer weiter der Standard werden.
Und keine Sorge, Leute,
denn das ist eine Feature,
nicht ein Bug.
Und wenn das JavaScript
für irgendeinen Grund nicht ladet,
dann, äh,
lassen wir uns nicht darüber kümmern.
Und deshalb fühlen sich
jede Webseite in diesen Tagen
nur langsam und blöd.
Das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht.
... und buggy.
Nun, viele Leute haben schon
darüber geredet.
Ja, das ist sicherlich
bei manchen Webseiten,
die scheiße gemacht sind.
Und ob die besser wären,
wenn die die Leute
manuell mit jQuery
zusammengewurstet hätten,
da habe ich wirklich
meine Zweifel.
Ich glaube sogar YouTube.
Ich glaube, YouTube verwendet
weder React noch Angular
noch sonst was.
Und das ist auch
lahmes Fuck oftmals.
Ja, sage ich ja.
Das ist auch der aktuelle Trend.
Und das wird auch in Zukunft
weiterhin zunehmen.
... Frameworks like Astro,
which I've previously covered
on this channel,
they combine things like
the nice developer experience
of using frameworks like React,
while keeping the end user in mind.
So you can use all of your cool
JavaScript frameworks,
but when the site builds,
it only uses JavaScript
when necessary.
So it still loads in HTML and CSS
like you would expect,
and it only uses JavaScript
when necessary.
Ja, Stream von gestern
hat auch gesagt,
dass es nur JavaScript
benutzt, wenn es notwendig ist.
So it still loads in HTML
and CSS
like you would expect,
when...
Ja, Stream von gestern
habe ich gelöscht.
Ich habe die letzte Stunde
nur noch an diesem
komischen Thermostat
rumgebastelt.
Das fand ich übelst langweilig.
... the site actually needs it
to be interactive.
And this is how things
are supposed to be.
Now, people are finally
kind of waking up
to this situation,
and people are taking
the trend of more sensible
frameworks with less JavaScript
shipped to the end user.
And I do think it is
a good thing,
but I still think that
it's kind of going
in the wrong direction,
because there are
the build process
is still extremely complex.
Das stimmt wohl.
Also alles, was Webpack
verwendet,
ist pepega
und kann man ja fast
unusable shit.
Webpack ist wirklich
eines der schlimmsten Sachen
überhaupt.
... and fragile.
Like in Astro,
this framework
that I reviewed,
it still needs
146 megabytes
of dependencies.
Das ist wenig.
... just to build
a basic hello world
with Astro.
So I'm still not
completely sold
to these new frameworks.
Now, it should go
without saying,
but for simple websites
that don't have a lot
of interactivity,
JavaScript is almost
never needed.
There are things like
static site generators now,
like Hugo,
which I have covered
in the past.
That is still one
of my favorite tools
that I use to build websites.
But these tools like Hugo,
they have never been better,
and you can build
huge, complex sites quickly,
and you don't have
to query a database
for every post
like you do
with something
like WordPress.
So for building small
or medium-sized websites,
this is definitely
the best option,
I think.
But I think just being aware
of all of the issues
with the modern web
is the best first step.
And when you're building
a new website
or a new project,
really ask yourself,
do you need
a JavaScript framework?
Even if it seems like
you're saving a lot of time
at the beginning,
you can run into
a lot of issues
down the road.
Sometimes the bigger website
is probably
notКöniglich
talk about
using
your website
in the modern
world.
So I have to say,
I thought the whole video
has it,
Okay, we'll go
through
it for the end.
Especially when we're
talking about
performance,
which can definitely
impact if people actually
want to use
your website or not.
And so,
before you start a new
project,
just ask yourself,
does it need
this framework
and is there any
better, more efficient
And my dream is that someday
I will be able to browse Reddit without having
to crash my browser.
Maybe someday. Bam! I can dream, right?
Also ich finde das aber jetzt alles
etwas überdramatisiert.
Ich sehe eher das Problem
im immer
nervig werdenderen
Webdesign für Desktop-User.
So wie Endless
Scroll und so ein Shit, was keine
Sau braucht auf dem Desktop.
Ja.
Das ist eher das Problem.
Nun gut, jetzt wissen wir ja, warum
JavaScript das Web ruiniert hat.
Ich habe da einiges anders gesehen
als er im Video.
iOS 17 Top Features.
iOS 17. Sekunde,
Sekunde. Gibt es da so viel geile
neuen Features?
Wurde vor einem Monat vorgestellt und eigentlich wollte ich
dieses für dich schon viel eher machen.
Frage. Nö, gucken wir uns
jetzt nicht an. Irgendwie kam ich nicht wirklich dazu.
Jetzt habe ich es endlich geschafft. iOS 17 ist auf meinem
iPhone installiert und getestet worden. Und das hier
sind meine sieben Lieblingsfeatures. Okay, auf
geht's.
Das wohl beste Feature ist wohl die Möglichkeit
nun endlich mehrere Timer
gleichzeitig zu... Oh mein Gott!
Apple hat sich wieder selbst übertroffen.
...stellen.
Okay, das wohl so ziemlich...
Das Einzige, was mich an iOS 17
Antrag so richtig begeistert hat, war
die Standby-Funktion. Damit könnt ihr
euer iPhone abends in eine super smarte
Nachttischuhr verwandeln. Damit kann man rein
theoretisch sogar ein HomePod...
Das ist das Erste, was ich abgeschaltet habe.
Das ist mir nämlich auch aufgefallen bei meinem neuen iPhone.
Das ist jetzt, wenn ich es sperre,
den Bildschirm nur noch freezed
oder dunkler macht, anstatt es komplett auszuschalten.
Das war das Erste, was ich ausgeschaltet habe.
...und das sogar mit einem
Display. Und ich sag's euch, je mehr
ich es genutzt habe, desto geiler
fand ich das Ganze. Es ist nicht einfach nur eine simple
Uhr oder ein Kalender, die Daten anzeigen
können, sondern das liegt daran, dass die
Widgets auf iOS 17 endlich nun nicht
mehr einfach nur hübsche, dumme Rechtecke
sind, die am Ende eigentlich nichts anderes
sind als Icons, die absolut
nichts können, sondern sie können auch wie bei Android
nun endlich angetippt und vernünftig bedient
werden. Damit kann ich dann zum Beispiel über die Standby-Funktion
Checklisten abhalten, smarte Automation
aktivieren oder Lichter bedienen.
Okay,
ja, ja, okay, ich
gette das, dass das für manche sicherlich cool
sein wird.
...wurde Siri nun endlich verbessert.
Man sagt nicht mehr wie früher, hey Siri, sondern einfach nur noch
Siri und das fühlt sich so viel
natürlicher an. So kann ich im Standby auch einfach Musik
über Siri starten und auch...
Ich hab Siri gar nicht an...
...steuern. Das ist so ein Feature... Doch, stimmt, ich hab Siri an.
Das ist für CarPlay voraus.
...Aufsetzung, witzigerweise.
Aber ich hab das, dieses, dieses
Listen, ständige Listen
nicht an. ...was ich wirklich mehrmals nutze,
während das iPhone einfach nur lädt.
Was ich auch einfach nur hammercool finde, ist, dass Apple
auch daran gedacht hat, einen Nachtmodus zu implementieren.
Sobald die Umgebung nämlich dunkel wird, wird
das Display automatisch abgedunkelt.
Alles erscheint in einem dunklen Rotton,
wie man es auch bei der Apple Watch Ultra kennt.
Der Stand, wo es den Apple auf der Keynote vorgestellt
hat, ist nicht zwingend notwendig.
Man könnte auch rein theoretisch einfach
das hier machen.
Man könnte das iPhone auch einfach
neben auf den Schrank legen oder
irgendwo
unter das Kissen oder...
...besitzt, wird diese Neuerung
lieben.
Shit, ein fremdes AirTag
bewegt sich mit mir.
Meine Freunde und mir ist es so, dass
jeder von uns jeweils einige AirTags
besitzen, die wir auch an Dinge rankleben,
die uns beide gehören, wie zum Beispiel
diese süße kleine...
...Maus hier. Das Problem ist, wenn ein AirTag
bei dir ist, was nicht auf deinen Namen
registriert ist, bekommst du aus Sicherheitsgründen
eine Benachrichtigung, dass ein AirTag in deiner
Nähe sich befindet, was nicht dir gehört.
Das hat jetzt natürlich riesen Vorteile,
wie zum Beispiel sich vor Stalkers zu schützen.
Das ganze Problem um dieses Thema habe ich bereits in einem...
AirTags befinden sich
in der Nähe, die nicht dir gehören.
Ah, wenn dich irgendeiner
tracken will mit AirTags, dann wird das jetzt
angezeigt oder so.
...anderen Video hier erklärt.
Okay.
...ist das bei mir so, dass ich so oft diese
Benachrichtigung bekomme, dass ich gar nicht mehr
wirklich darauf achte. Mit iOS 17
kann man AirTags nun auch endlich
teilen. Dadurch bekommt man einerseits nicht mehr
diese nervige Benachrichtigung, aber vor allem
können nun mehrere auf demselben
AirTag zugreifen, sprich auch danach
suchen. So kann ich nun auch endlich immer
nachsehen, wo das Portemonnaie meiner Freundin ist,
falls ich ein bisschen Geld brauche.
Ein bisschen, ein bisschen runter. Sag tschüss.
Tschüss.
Apropos Geld. Viele von euch haben in meinem letzten
Video kommentiert, dass das Produkt, was ich dort vorgestellt
habe, zwar cool ist, aber irgendwie
viel zu teuer sei. Deswegen wünsche ich euch den heutigen
Sponsor Dreamy und deren neuestes
Produkt von AirTags und erfüllt diesen
geschrappten Robins neues Feature, bei dem ich zuerst
dachte, oh mein Gott, ist
das unnötig. Bis zu dem
Zeitpunkt, an dem ich es wirklich aktiv
genutzt habe. Mit iOS 17 kann man nämlich
persönliche Visitenkarten erstellen, welche dann
mit anderen Personen geteilt werden kann.
Übertragen wird das Ganze nämlich über...
Okay.
Geht das jetzt erst?
Dachte, du konntest deine Kontakte schon ewig
sharen.
Über AirDrop.
Ja, ich dachte, es geht
schon lange. Okay, aber vielleicht nicht
mit so einem coolen Visitenkartenbild und sowas.
Der Gedanke, dass das Ganze
unnötig ist, verflog
sobald ich realisiert habe, dass sobald ich
etwas an meiner Karte verändere, wie zum Beispiel meine
E-Mail oder mein Foto, bei allen, die mich als
Kontakt abgespeichert haben, sich ebenfalls
mit aktualisieren. Zudem wurde das Feature auch
allgemein in AirDrop implementiert. Sprich, wenn
ich jemandem etwas über AirDrop zusenden möchte,
kann ich einfach mein iPhone an seines halten,
für die Übertragung. Hier geht es um
alle Verbesserungen, die etwas mit... Ich hab,
by the way, ich hab AirDrop aus. Ich schalte es immer nur ein,
wenn ich mal irgendwie was in und her schieben muss.
Sprache und Text zu tun haben. Da einige
Freunde von mir iMessage benutzen, bin ich gelegentlich
dazu gezwungen, dies auch
zu tun. Und hier bin ich so froh
darüber, dass man nun endlich eine Nachricht im
Chat reinziehen kann, um direkt darauf
zu antworten. Das ist eine Funktion, die ich auf WhatsApp
wirklich immer nutze.
Zudem wurde nun die Diktierfunktion verbessert. Was
mich an meinem Pixel immer so hammer gereizt hat,
war die KI unterstützte Spracheingabe.
Das Ganze geht nun endlich auch auf dem iPhone.
Und das funktioniert wirklich gut.
Fast so gut wie auf meinem Pixel. Das liegt
daran, dass Apple nun endlich an der Autokorrektur
gearbeitet hat. Und das merkt man zu
jeder Sekunde. Das Problem mit den ganzen KI-Sprachmodellen
bei Apple ist jedoch, dass Deutsch noch
nicht so richtig implementiert wurde. Auf Englisch
funktioniert das Ganze deutlich besser und sogar
besser als beim Pixel.
Mit eigener Stimme lernt eine KI, wie du
sprichst und kann deine Stimme über Nacht
komplett nachbauen. Dafür musst du
150 Sätze ablesen, aus denen dann
eine künstliche Stimme generiert wird.
Und das dauert so
lange. Finde ich hammer cool,
aber auch irgendwie hammer gruselig, dass das einfach jetzt
so jeder... Und... Und dann?
...machen kann. Leider sind die KI-Sprachmodelle
wie gesagt auf Deutsch noch nicht verfügbar.
Deswegen habe ich das Ganze einfach mal auf Englisch gemacht und das Ganze
klingt ungefähr so.
Hallo, meine Liebe in Suzhou. Ich habe
euch als Sarah lieb.
Naja, da habe ich aber schon bessere
synthetische Stimmen-AI-Sachen
gehört in den letzten Monaten.
Eine Sekunde, weshalb ich immer wieder zum iPhone greife,
ist FaceTime. Die Bildqualität, die
Soundqualität, die Verbindungsstabilität,
das alles ist so viel besser
als bei WhatsApp. Nun kamen mit iOS 17 so
einige Features für FaceTime, die ich ziemlich cool finde.
Meine absolute Lieblingserneuerung
hier ist die Möglichkeit, Videonachrichten
zu hinterlassen, wenn ein Anruf nicht angenommen
wurde. Da könnte man jetzt auch einfach rein theoretisch
eine Sprachnachricht oder ein Video
zusenden, aber das ist halt immer ein Prozess, was man
nicht gerne macht. Zudem empfinde ich persönlich
einen Anruf immer wichtiger als
eine Sprach- oder Textnachricht.
Deswegen schätze ich die Möglichkeit...
Ich nicht. Ich finde Textnachrichten,
Nachrichten viel angenehmer, als wenn
mich jemand anruft. Die sollen mir nicht auf den Sack gehen.
Eine Textnachricht reicht.
Eine simple Videonachricht zu hinterlassen, sehr.
Dann gibt es noch so einige Kleinigkeiten, die ich echt cool fand,
wie zum Beispiel Offline-Kartenansichten
oder die Check-In-Funktion. Aber an sich waren
das meine sieben Lieblings-Highlights für iOS 17.
Es ist wirklich nicht das beste Update,
aber nachdem ich das Ganze getestet habe, ist...
Aha.
Na dann.
So mega gehypt hat's
mich jetzt nicht. Oh nein!
Einer, der keinen Bock mehr auf Neowim hat.
Ich nicht. Nice.
Das ist ein guter Name für eine Eisdiele.
Ja, erst mal das halbe Internet runterladen.
Interessant.
Anyway, let's google
best Node.js Web-Server.
Only the best for this Web.
Express kommt da jetzt.
Let's see here.
Express braucht halt irgendwie
3 GB JavaScript oder so.
Alright, let's check that out.
NPM install Express.
Okay, we're just gonna copy and paste
that. Oh, schlechte Idee.
Schlechte Idee.
Copy and paste that.
What the hell is this?
I guess everyone needs the points.
That's not bad.
I heard Node was a lot heavier than this.
Wait, what the hell happened?
400 MB.
Come on.
4 GB?
No, this is bullshit.
I gotta stop.
How do I stop?
I'm slamming CTRL-C.
How do I stop this thing?
Okay, ich gette den Gag, ja?
Da gibt's ja dieses Meme-Bild
schon ewig mit
Node Modules
Black Hole
Heaviest Objects in the Universe.
Sun, Neutronen,
Und Stern, schwarzes Loch, Note Modules.
So, Leute.
Was gibt's heute zu essen?
Ratet mal.
Und ihr werdet wahrscheinlich richtig liegen.
Lachs mit Nudel, korrekt.
Lachs mit Nudel gibt's heute.
So sieht's aus.
Ich geh jetzt was essen, Leute. Wir sehen uns.
Bis denn.
See you.